e e
look
it's a small enough
world e
oh 10:01 we might as well get
started look at
this it's not yeah it arrived
today there you
go very enthusiastic yeah right person
yeah so there was one little agency here
that we hadn't
seen um yet and this is they're on page
102 two so we have somebody here from
the Personnel appeals board
welcome and I guess you're attached to
something like Das I
guess yeah so it's 102 and
um so please introduce yourself oh good
morning Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is marilene Ian I am a
member of the Personnel Board of Appeals
I am accompanied here with our chairman
uh Attorney Charles
Russell uh
and um so we're going to tell you a
little bit about who we are and what we
do and then we'll explain our budget to
you sound good perfect um you can find
our budget on page 1021 three in your
budget book I know some of you are
already there um the Personnel appeals
board was established in 1986 is a
qualified independent panel appointed by
the governor and Council under the
provisions of RSA 21
I45 and RSA
273d to hear Personnel could you repeat
that 21 uh yes it's in the handout
ah thank you very much
sorry uh the board conducts hearings on
appeals from classified state employees
who wish to challenge adverse
disciplinary actions taken by appointing
authorities such as letters of warning
suspensions and
terminations in addition to conducting
hearings management of these cases
includes Communications with party reps
conducting preher conferences
deliberating motions and concluded
hearings responding to Supreme Court and
right to no request and conducting
periodic business
meetings the board is a
quasi judicial body that requires the
chairperson and the vice chairperson to
be members of the New Hampshire bar the
other members there are five of us in
total the other members provide
experience in Labor Relations personnel
management and human resource
Administration each board member must
have the knowledge experience and
expertise to conduct sound hearings and
render thoughtful and fair decisions
many cases that come before the board
involve complex facts arguments and
legal issues that require days of
testimony followed by thoughtful and
timeconsuming deliberation
Among Us board
members we receive approximately 25 to
35 cases a year some cases are resolved
relatively quickly uh which is always
our goal uh while more complex cases can
live on for a few
years uh a little bit about our budget
now historically the Personnel appeals
board has been a component within uh the
division of
personnel uh last legislative session
Senate Bill
487 established that the PAB should be
an independent state
agency thus we are coming before you
with our very first operating budget
this budget is consistent with the
fiscal note that was attached to the
Senate bill
our
budget request total for
2026 is
$353,500
4 $
33477 we are a generally funded
agency the budget includes routine
operating costs such as office supplies
equipment
utilities
um and information technology software
and
Hardware our class 50 line uh which is
the part-time uh Personnel line includes
two new hope that doesn't alarm you too
much but I want to be straightforward um
to new part-time Personnel to manage the
board's operations a program director
and a
pargal this Staffing plan uh is modeled
after the PE lb the personal the public
employees Labor Relations Board which
has an executive director a paralal and
several attorneys on
staff these two part-time positions are
new people so are you saying these two
people are not yet hired correct I see
thank you correct it's it part of what
we're doing in this particular budget is
building the infrastructure to be an
independent
agency um for startup costs fiscal year
2026 you'll notice that 26 is a little
higher than 27 which is not usually the
case in a banal budget r26 includes
um onetime expenses such as office
furniture
computers um and other
equipment I wanted to talk really
quickly about the ways that we
already try to manage our budget
efficiently
um uh we put forth a um very
lean um budget request for you um the
part-time staff versus full-time staff
um partly because our case load doesn't
warrant a full-time staff person but
also we're trying to um stay away from
the added expense of benefits of a
full-time staff person um this does
include funding for four board members
rather than the authorized five
um searching for we are we don't even
have our own space yet we're we're
working on that as we speak um we are
looking for um part
state-owned office space and courtroom
hearing space um rather than having to
rent out privately are you saying there
aren't five members of the board
there interestingly enough
um I've been on the board since
2017 um we've always had
four um and more recently we've dropped
down to three we are required to have a
three for a quorum so if we only have
three board members to work with it
doesn't give us any flexibility if
somebody's out sick that sort of thing
um
involves you know delay of of hearings
which is very costly for everybody
involved are board members paid board
members are pay to stien yes so much per
day per hour for we get um we get uh
$400 per day for a day of hearings plus
uh $200 every two weeks for work done
outside of hearings such as prep work um
writing decisions that sort of thing
gotcha yes representative evil I I don't
want to jump ahead of your presentation
but um put right I was just going to ask
Jack if he could get us the related bill
that did this but I'm I'm not familiar
with this did you say you originally is
under Das yes so to some extent um while
some of this general fund use may be new
some of it was already being expended
when you were part of Das yeah do do you
know what the the difference is I mean
you Pro did you share space with them
and I'm just trying
to we have relied on the space and staff
and resources um from admin
services I don't want to speak on their
behalf but I think they would tell you
that our departure does not leave a big
enough hole
that their could be reduced or that we
could bring those Resources with us
right I guess I I was mostly trying to
just identify the the connection there
so for us because we're hearing we're
hearing the budgets of many sorts of
boards like this so thank you yeah
representative MS uh than thank you Mr
chair and U for representative eel's
benefit I'm looking at the bill right
now and uh what's interesting that the
bill was a it was a request from the
Department of administrative services do
you do thank you for coming in um do you
have any idea what the reason for that
was yes I do um there have been so we
hear cases from All State agencies
um including admin
Services um and there have been times
when commissioner Arling house has come
before
us um asking us to uphold a decision
that he has made um and it can be very
awkward um so we searched around
for a better
home um at one point we thought well
maybe we would align nicely with the
Department of Justice because we do some
similar work but they are also state
employees um and have the potential to
come before us so ultimately it was
determined that the best route for us to
take was to become um an independent
agency representative
Griffin thank you thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question I did a
quick calculation here based on 25 to 35
cases a year it looks like the average
case is costing 10 to
12,000 that seems to me like a lot of
money for an appeal of an administrative
decision maybe you could shed some light
on why why it costs so
much I guess the one thing thing I could
say in response to your question which
is a very reasonable question um is that
if we didn't have this
board
um these cases would be going through
our court
system um and be taking
up much more
expensive um
time not only for the court system but
for the Representatives that work on
behalf of these state
employees I don't have a figure as to
how expensive that would be but just by
Logic and what we probably all know
about the coure system it is not as
efficient a route as this process is
here um thank you you follow okay let me
ask you on this I assume this $400 a day
and $200 a day that's not new right
you've been doing that for a while yeah
so how many days were there um in fiscal
year last year last year fiscal year
24 um of the 400 type and of the 200
type well the 200 is paid out every two
weeks so that's essentially $400 a month
times
12 okay so that's all automatic sort of
right yes yes got you okay so so 25
weeks per year per person yes and you
now have three right so yeah correct
okay gotcha um I I will comment that um
the governor and Council approved a new
board member at their last
meeting um and they are scheduled to
approve a fifth member at their next
scheduled meeting understand okay um and
um and so how many days of hearings did
you have we probably had you know this I
I did I did the math um I think there
were 20 24 days of hearings yes and
sometimes you might have a two-day
hearing there's also a rule there's also
a rule that says um if you have cases
pending you can't go more than 30 days
without a meeting to keep the pressure
on to move it through but but I think I
think um in last year's budget or the
budget cycle we're in I think um there's
a lot of hidden costs in there that uh
Personnel Department was picking up
there's already a woman uh Lisa who's
moving on to another position that
pretty much does what the uh
administrative staff is doing scheduling
getting orders then there's a right to
no request and it's taken forever to put
the record together and a lot of news
media pushing and then the Supreme Court
appeal so there is one employee already
doing quite a bit of this work but and
she's not paid
independent right she's absorbed in the
Das budget somewhere yeah yeah okay and
in the 24 days of
hearings do you have all the board
members who are available go to that
hearing or is it you pick three and and
we'll take three for that hearing um
we given that we haven't had a full
compliment of five until just recently
um we typically have all board members
attend I I think it is
helpful
um when it comes to the decisions that
the board makes to have a variety of
experiences and opinions at the table
yes thank you representative
Griffin um thank you thank you for
taking the question um are the decisions
of the board final or do people have the
ability to appeal and go to
court they do have the ability to appeal
they typically will ask us for
reconsideration if they think that we've
missed something important in our
deliberation
um
and we will deliberate those
reconsideration requests um they
do have the right to go to Supreme
Court represent months repes and
followed by representative R thank thank
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question again I have I have two two
questions um first just to make sure I'm
I'm clear the State Labor Relations
Board they handle all the
union issues correct correct they handle
contractual issues corre we handle
um non-union nonunion per state
Personnel rules only okay all right that
was my first question thank you and then
secondly um and and thank you for for uh
explaining the rationale for creating an
independent agency so I I I I understand
that now um but given given that um I'm
assuming that
previously you were housed within the
department of administrative Services
physically yes um is there any reason
you couldn't continue to be housed there
physically using your exact same your
your your exact space without
needing um you know without forfeiting
your ability to be
independent right now
we share a part we share part of a
person
um who also has other duties within um
administrative
Services um the space that we have there
is her
cubby
with um all her other files and other
work that
exists so to be an independent state
agency we are going to need our own
address our own
telephone um so that our our repr the
lawyers and and the staff who need our
services know where to go
to seek our
resources I think it would it's a let me
just
say it would not achieve the level of
Independence that's um contemplated all
right follow up
um and thank you again for that
explanation um given the fact that um
there is some similarity between the
work that you do and the State Labor
Relations Board granted it's a different
population that you're
serving is there have you looked at the
opportunity of maybe collocating with
them yes yes we did early on in this um
disc discussion to be
independent um I went over there to
explore with their executive director
Douglas ingersol it's been a couple
years since I've talked to him so I had
to resurrect his name um I went over
there just to talk about how is their
budget organized what does their office
set up look like um and and actually to
see if he had the space and the desire
to partner with us um
and
he was not interested in doing so for
whatever
reason okay all right representative R
thank you Mr chair um so how many
employees what are the potential number
of employees that you serve because
you're not serving the employees who are
under a collective bargaining agreement
correct state employees have a
collective baring agreement and
also
[Music]
are um not only responsible but the
state is responsible for complying with
Personnel administrative
rules so we hear cases that claim
violation of administ ative rule even
state employees if they have a
bargaining issue will go to the other
elrb
organization okay so you potentially
could hear cases from any employee in
the state employ state employee okay and
how many do you know how many there are
total I 10 12,000 the last but it's been
a few years since
I've worked full-time in stake govern so
that might be stale so don't okay and
you hear about you said 25 to 30 a year
has that been consistent I mean you've
only been in operation for a couple
years so since 86 oh 86 okay yeah and
actually we existed under prior under a
different model even prior to 86 so
we've been around
for close to a century okay so have you
seen the number of employees cases come
before you increase over that time or
have they stayed pretty steady certainly
I we have a um our website has an annual
report required to do an annual report I
looked at it yesterday I'm sorry I
didn't bring it but it is online and it
has like a 10-year list of how many
cases how many were dismissed how many
were approved how many were a lot of
them are settled because they start
there's a free interchange of
information between the employee uh the
union representative of SE rep or they
have independent councel and the agency
councel and so there are some years I
know in the last uh 10 and I've only
been on the board a year and a half that
there were upwards of 40 cases but so um
and and the the issues are you have a
big Personnel uh code that they if if
somebody didn't get the reclassification
or didn't get the right what they think
is a proper discipline they bring it to
us and we have some discretion to decide
what
um is appropriate they may have been
terminated for something and maybe the
the next level I think is like a 20-day
suspension without pay and then we could
have a warning and some other things so
it's kind of and and I've never been
part
of organization I've been an independent
attorney and it's interesting to see the
the Dynamics of what goes on within an
agency and whether it's somebody was uh
applying a different standard um to a um
to an older person who may not not be as
familiar with what they U what is the
respect and civility code that came in
in 2020s some we see some older uh
people coming in older employees that
don't kind of seem to understand that so
maybe the maybe a termination is not
appropriate thing but so um and it
offers a fairly hopefully expeditious
way of dealing with it rather than have
it going to court and the court has to
set you up in 3 months and 6 months and
nine months and then if we reverse it
then you're faced with the issue of the
employeer is re reinstated with back pay
and you don't want to have a year or two
of back pay laying out there as well
you'd rather get an expeditious uh
decision fairly quickly so okay a couple
more questions yeah go ahead Andes so um
the cases that you've heard that you've
made decisions upon what I you know just
approximately how what percentage would
you say supports the Management's
decision regarding that situation and
the percentage that support the
employees
position I I I I think I looked at the
last year's annual report that ended
June 30th last year and there were 22
cases there were there were four that
were overturned that found for the
employee okay uh there were nine that
were dismissed and there were nine that
were settled which we don't we just get
case withdrawn we don't know which way
it went we assume if it was settled
either the employee got tired found
another job or the state so the settled
count is part of this 30 cases a year
roughly yes and so there's pressure
there to do it and and I assume um you
you can also go to the website literally
go back and they classify disciplinary
termination classification letters of
warning and you literally can go back
and pull up somebody's you can
alphabetically pull up a case from 1986
I mean it goes continuously and that's
part of the in the budget for us to
maintain that website which we're going
to lose from uh from administrative
services so and that that provides some
guidance I think as well for the state
as well as the employees they certainly
there's more than 22 employees that get
some sort of discipline within the year
the question is and there's also before
it gets to us there's a five-step
process where internally with the agency
they will start talking let's do this
and then the union rep comes in and then
they go to this and they go to that so
there's like four or five steps before
they ever then they get the final
decision and then they have 15 days to
file with us so um we don't know how
they turn out we don't know how many
settled because there's some precedent
that that wasn't that wasn't a
terminable offense it was only a 20-day
offense or it was only a letter of
warning okay thank you sorry that take
so long no it's very interesting you
said the website is going away what do
you mean by that so I don't think
Personnel um uh I don't think uh
administrative Services wants to carry
it we're going to have to move it over
so we have to set up a website to carry
this and and then and we're trying to
get as I understand it um Mary Lee is is
more into the technical aspects within
setting up the agency but
um um we're we're TR I'm sorry I lost my
point we're trying to um do it like the
court system system and you know that
you can go in you can look at all the
filings all you can do is just hit it
and you can look at the whole pleading
as opposed to somebody you know right
now we have a rule original in five
copies you know I'm I'm a veteran and
I'm I'm still living by paper doing as
much on internet but presumably doit can
keep your pages current yeah we're
working we're working with them aren't
we yes okay yes so yep okay very good
any other representative eil just really
quickly because we're at the end of the
line here um so if there's an appeal
that has to be filed does it have to go
through your board first or do people
have the opportunity to also go to the
Superior Court they have to go through
our board first okay that's the process
okay thank you okay and how many times
are you appealed to court very
infrequently I guess
or um interestingly when I first joined
the board it was very rare that a case
went to Superior Court um more recently
I'm going to say within the last year
and a half to two years um our cases
have been much more um
contentious um and
contested
and we've had we've probably got four
cases right now four or five cases cases
before Superior Court um from from both
sides some from the state didn't like
our decision and some of the terminated
employees didn't like her decision okay
does that do you your any of your board
members then have to go to court or not
really we do not have to go to court but
we do provide them with a huge amount of
information um you're right up for them
to make their
decisions thank you very much AG that uh
advises us gotcha okay thank you all
right well thank you very
much yes thanks for coming so
rep yeah I saw that yeah I I can ask her
about it um so let's go to we have next
um the council for developmental
disabilities and they are on page 156 to
158 and the the important thing to
notice about these guys is I believe
they are 100% federal funds you stole my
thunder
okay yeah so good line yeah so you know
we we try to talk to everybody just to
you know cross the te's and off the eyes
but all right so welcome and please
introduce
yourself good
morning good morning my name is isidora
Rodriguez legendre I serve as the
executive director at the New Hampshire
Council on developmental
disabilities as you stated uh we are
100% federally funded through um a
federal law that we lovingly refer to as
the DD act so it's the developmental
disabilities assistance and Bill of
Rights Act most recently reauthorized in
2000 um which states that every state
and territory should have a
developmental disabilities
Council uh dedicated to identifying the
most pressing needs of individuals with
intellectual and developmental
disabilities in that state and or
territory and then we develop a
five-year plan to address those needs um
what I uh say is that we could not do
what we do without collaboration and so
most we collaborate with other entities
including the State Department of Health
and Human Services Bureau of
Developmental services and other
disability related
organizations um how we differ from the
governor's Council on disability it's
usually a question I get is that um our
charge is very specifically for
individuals with intellectual and
developmental disabilities and are
guiding federal law is the DD act
whereas they their guiding federal law
is the Ada and they're more concerned
with
accessibility um and uh are not limited
to a specific disability so they serve
you know individuals who are blind DEA
in heart of hearing Etc whereas we are
very specifically uh developmental
disabilities and those are disabilities
identified before the age of 22 which
are expected to have a lifelong impact
on people's lives and um more often than
not depend on lifelong supports and
services through um uh Medicaid funded
Services typically um to provide support
for people with disabilities um I've
provided for you just the general kind
of um information about our mission the
DD act itself um and Council membership
so by law 60% of our membership must be
individuals impacted by intellectual and
developmental disab abilities and or
parents are guardians of individuals who
cannot advocate for themselves because
of a developmental disability um and
then uh I also provided an infographic
of both our um mission statement and our
Five-Year Plan we have two main goals
and that is quality of life to address
barriers of daily living for people with
intellectual and developmental
disabilities and what that typically
means is removing those barriers that
limit access to participation in
People's Community um and then the other
goal is related to advocacy and training
so we partner with a lot of
organizations to do like voter rights
trainings and um provide uh technical
assistance for information access how to
make
materials um easy to read or um provide
infographics for those who have very
limited uh reading capab ility um the
last hand that I provided to you is our
most recent notice of award I find it
helpful to kind of explain a little bit
about how our funding works so on an
annual basis Congress desde decides what
our um Federal award will be in their
budget as you can imagine we don't know
what that will be yet since we are in a
continuing resolution and we've kind of
gotten uh our little chunks of funding
um through the continuing resolution
period so right now we've received
$121 uh
,000 um through the continuing
resolution and then once Congress uh
decides on a budget we will know what we
will get for the rest of the year we
work on a federal fiscal year and our
grant award even though it's annually
alloted is good for a 2-year period so
that allows us to carry funds forward um
um and the other thing that's important
to know about our organization is that
we work on a reimbursement so federal
funds are spent the state kind of fronts
us the operating expenses and then we
draw down and we're currently drawing
down on a monthly basis to uh to
reimburse the state for the costs of
operating our program we have three
full-time positions and three part-time
positions um we're not requesting any
new positions um but we are eliminating
a full-time position that we had on the
books that is no longer being funded um
and that's pretty you had been for
fulltime so no so what happened was
during the pandemic we found it very
difficult to fill positions and we had
decided that what we were going to do is
split one of those full-time positions
into two part-time positions in the
hopes that we could get you know a mom
that needed mother's hours or something
like that to be able to do the two
pieces um one was related to projects
and one was related to kind of policy
work or following bills during the
legislative session um which we do a
fair amount of since a lot of bills are
related to developmental disabilities
access and inclusion um and it didn't
really work out we found an individual
to fill one of the part-time positions
and decided that instead of continuing
to try and recruit for the second one to
just make that position full-time and so
it's actually replaced the one that was
on the books previously gotcha now uh
one of the big increases in your budget
is in class 72 fed grants so you're
handing out grants yes and in 2024 it
was only $30,000 but now it's going up
to 200 plus yeah so what is that about
that's a great question thank you for
asking so a lot of how we do our work is
through grants we have about seven
different types of Grants we have grants
for individuals grants for organizations
something that we call um Innovation
grants so for a new idea on how to
better include people with disabilities
in community um so we kind of put those
out and we get applications for those um
in that year we had very few I would say
fewer grants than what we budgeted for
the other thing is that um the the
federal government requires us to have
an objective on our fiveyear plan
related to what they call a targeted
disparity and our targeted disparity we
intended to put out a an RFP we did
actually put an RFP twice and did not
get applicants and so we had a blotted a
big chunk of our funding towards that
work and it didn't get funded and that's
kind of why we hope we anticipate being
able to address that goal again through
grants this coming
vium um so we have again allotted the
funding it's anybody's guess if we will
be able to contract uh successfully but
we're we're hopeful that we would be
able to do that does that kind of
funding la if you don't spend it it does
not lapse um our funding because it's
reimbursement by reimbursement if we
don't spend it we don't draw it down so
it's still kind of in the bank uh
waiting for us to uh in the federal bank
or in the in the Federal in the Federal
Bank I see so does that mean and it's
not frozen at the moment so so because
because you didn't spend it in 2004 you
could you could spend it in 2005
because we have a 2year um project
period and what's uh helpful with that
is as we go through the year and see how
our funding is shaping up we can
actually put more funding into other
types of Grants or activities to not
have so high of a carry forward moving
forward so actually in the governor's
budget um the uh uh the
authorized um amounts for the next bium
are guesstimates based on what we've
been receiving annually about you know
between $450 and
$550,000 a year so we have a small
budget but we typically carry forward
between two and
$300,000 so that in the event of
government shutdowns and continuing
resolutions we still have funds on which
to draw while we're waiting to hear from
Congress what our allotment will be for
the next fiscal year now do you ever
deal with cases or individuals who have
complaints or something like that no we
do a fair amount of referrals to um
different entities responsible for those
things so we refer people to for example
the cap program at the governor's
Commission on disability if they have an
issue with VOC Vocational Rehabilitation
we refer people to the disability rights
center for legal Assistance or
information if they have a a rights
violation issue we do get a lot of calls
related to things like you know neglect
abuse exploitation and we refer those
appropriately to the entities that are
responsible for investigating those
gotcha representative Ms thank you Mr
chair thank you for coming in and um as
a father of a young man with a
developmental disability thank you for
all the work that um the council has
been doing over the years to raise um
visibility um just a question for you uh
a two-part question around the same
theme um have you experienced any uh
difficulties drawing down federal funds
in the last couple
months so there there was about a week
and a half there where all of the
federal systems for drawing down were
unavailable um but
since that time we've drawn down twice
and without there have been additional
delays but nothing sign what I would
call significant and maybe it takes an
extra week to get our funding into the
State Bank okay thank you and then the
second question is um and I and I know
it's difficult to um to to predict but
have you gotten any sense at all as to
you know how your funding may be
affected by some of the um uh uh
proposals to uh reduce federal spending
that is a great question um so uh as
many federally funded
entities uh we are cautiously optimistic
we have been told by our National
Organization to prepare for
contingencies that may uh
significantly impact our funding um
however uh our review of the federal law
the DD act does indicate a minimum
allotment amount of somewhere in the
realm of
$400,000 so we're hopeful that I mean
unless they change the federal law um
that we will at least be able to receive
that um
certainly the last couple of months have
caused a lot of confusion about what can
and can't be done related to funding um
but we are um created by the DD act and
funded through the DD act so our
cautious optimism is that that cannot
easily be
defunded um although there were attempts
in the first Administration
to um in this president first
Administration
to um combine different Federal funded
disability programs that was not
successful we do have a lot of members
of Congress that are app parents and and
that understand the importance of our
work and of inclusion in community for
people with developmental disabilities
so again our our understanding is that
um regardless of U political we're
nonpartisan entity and so we feel as
though there are sufficient people in
Congress to that really get what we do
and that um understand the impact that
we have in the state and it's not that
much money right it's it's less than
half a million dollars that's in the DD
act so so okay representative R thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question um do you have a website or an
annual report where I can learn more
about your this specific projects that
are funded through your office yes we
have both um and I would be happy to
send uh the annual report and the
website link to the committee membership
that would be great thank you sure all
right now you you showed us this example
of a grant of
$121,000 is this the kind of thing you
get
quarterly monthly some other kind of
regular schedule so so it's interesting
thank you for the question um because
I've I've been here for um coming up on
nine years and it really es and flows
from from year to year it's hard to
predict um there are certain grants that
we expect annually to support different
congre conferences and training
activities we also have a pretty um
wellp publicized accessibility Grant so
if any group or organization is putting
on a community event and they need ASL
interpreters or cart captioning Services
they can apply to our organizations for
funds to assist in paying for those
things which improves the accessibility
for people with disabilities in New
Hampshire um but other than that it's
really difficult unless we have a
specific Target in our Five-Year Plan
because all of our grants are are driven
by our 5-year plan and and The Five-Year
Plan is driven by the m MIP of the
council um it's really hard to tell how
many Grant requests we're going to get
in a year and kind of for how much um
we've done a number of really great and
interesting uh grants recently for
things like accessible playgrounds
accessible hiking trails um really uh
accessible we did one for an accessible
boat launch um uh the um
the Autobon put in uh push doors for uh
folks who need push doors for entry and
we gave them a small amount of money we
also um I think the um one of the
museums is creating more accessibility
like an accessible bathroom things like
that um so those are kinds of things
that we want and typically fund is
things that make the space is um more
inclusive in New Hampshire the reason
I'm asking this question is you're
budgeting for roughly $800,000 a year so
in order to meet that you're going to
need six or seven of
these right
so or maybe some of them are bigger or
or whatever yeah no that's that's a
that's a great question um so that
800,000 typically a little more than
half goes on personnel and overhead
right um and then we have uh the council
votes on an in internal budget for like
how much we're going to put towards
Grant on an annual basis and um I think
that this is a little bit misleading in
that one we don't know what Congress is
going to approve in the next bium and so
we're going off of what our level
funding would be from the last two years
um it's not guaranteed though and then
the second thing is that this is
anticipating a carry forward that is not
typical for us we don't typically carry
forward
$400,000 a year but when we develop the
budget we are told in the agency phase
for the Governor's phase that we need to
put down every single dollar that we
could
potentially
receive even if that is just a
guesstimate and if you end up short then
you will dial back absolutely absolutely
okay okay you want to make
your okay um thank you very much Mr
chair I'd like to make a motion to
approve the uh budget as presented for
the New Hampshire Council on
developmental disabilities I'll second
that motion okay any
discussion seems Seems fairly
straightforward all right show of hands
in favor looks unanimous okay thank you
very much have a great day great job
okay now the next one on our schedule
and we have another 10 minutes is one
we've already saw last week
so um
did I screw up in I wondered repeating I
wondered okay I
see
is somebody's calling so I'm yeah and
here they
are so unfortunately we can't start
early but um did we did we run short is
that what happened on the they only had
15 minutes out of the half an hour or or
they were only scheduled
I see and we were talking about more
stuff yeah okay so we will restart at at
11: okay
okay yeah because you want yeah okay
good so we'll we'll turn to you for more
questions all
right
e
e e
all right it's 11 o'clock please come up
and you guys are on page 109 and
110 and yeah I guess I just felt that um
you were here before but
it seemed rushed right
so um and and as representative Ms
pointed out who's not here but he wasn't
here they come back again yeah right so
so yeah
um
okay so
um okay
I guess
um maybe uh for the benefit of
Representative rang you might want to
just give you know a two-minute or three
minute explanation of what you do and um
how long you've been here and uh so on
yes thank you good morning Kristen
monani advocate for special education
Tim Lenahan assistant
Advocate I don't want to repeat a lot of
what we said before so I'm I'm going to
be very um summary with it uh we did um
on the first page of the presentation
sort of sketch out what the statutory
mandates were and they fall into
categories of of case management case
resolution in order to ensure that
services are provided um Data Tracking
in order to understand what's going on
um data was something that I I was
really surprised in taking the office
that we just don't have as much data
um or data that's as accurate on special
education as we would really like it to
be and we are talking with the
Department of Ed about that it's been
something that I know they've been
focused on for a while and are actually
working to get some systems in place um
to get us more data I I'll just add to
that because I'm I'm on I'm on the
education funding committee and we've
been discussing bills so right now the
way the state pays for special ed that
the the high-end case
is something used to be called
catastrophic Aid we now just call it
special ed Aid or something I anyways we
pay uh there's the Statewide average
cost for for education of
$21,000 roughly a year and so whenever a
particular kid uh a school district is
spending on that kid more than three and
a half times that Statewide average so
roughly
$70,000 uh maybe 75 $5,000 then the
state will pay um the uh 70% of the ne
of the costs of that kid up to 10 times
that average so up to up to
$210,000 okay and then over the $210,000
the state will pay 100% okay although
there's another issue about this because
the overall spending is capped right so
there's there's a what called pration
but anyways but there's a formula and so
we have we have bills where we're
talking about what if we changed the
three and a half
times um down to three what would that
cost us right and we don't
know right because they don't report
anything on every special ed kid right
how much are we spending on it we know I
guess they sort of report overall
statistics but the but the problem is
you know they might have somebody on
staff who for this kid you know does 10%
of their time and on that kid it's 15%
of the time and on this you know and so
there's no way of
knowing or exactly what's the cost of
Any Given kid right and so and so
changing those numbers would be a
complete um guessing game of of you know
what's the effect on the state budget if
we made a change right and so it's very
difficult sorry doing so it just to pick
up on that so that we're having a fluid
conversation um it with some Data
Tracking with our understanding from a
fieldwork level um in there in the teams
looking at IEP by IEP and understanding
how to how to cost build in an IEP um
we've been also doing policy work um we
are getting to the point where we have
several Representatives who are reaching
out and saying what do you think about
this bill tell me about this piece of
language even if it's one that we were
not involved in putting in front of them
and and we've gotten positive feedback
on our being kind of useful and very
direct um in in that uh with the funding
question um I I will say I did um submit
written testimony to the committee
saying you know what about what if it's
not three and but two and a half um this
data question we we don't have the data
we are doing Data Tracking for our own
case load but we really do understand
what's happening as IEPs get built so as
we move towards a model that we
absolutely need Statewide of Labor
costing and being able to really look at
each IEP and have districts look at each
of their IEPs so that we can get a
handle on how we're not trading off
between special education and general
education as much because that that is a
serious tension at the moment in the
state as special ed cost rise we we have
to be better and we're trying to be
involved in that conversation because we
really do understand exactly how these
these I APS are getting built um we do a
very minimal amount of referral sum but
honestly more things are referred to us
and my colleague is going to talk about
that uh a bit I'd just love to say you
know as we do this work in case
management in Data Tracking in policy um
both both promulgating um two
legislators suggestions and being there
for questions and for feedback on bills
that come up um we we've asked for a
staff of five in the office um have a
really concrete kind of plan and idea as
to how uh those get used right now it's
us um with a very very minimal amount of
part-time help um one day or or less a
week uh solely based on budget um from
from a third
person I don't see us coming back and
saying if we could get this office of
five I don't see us coming back and
saying we need more we need more we need
more um we really can do some training
measures and start to put a lot into the
field that we're not finding is there
right now um to help private Advocates
do some of this work to help parents do
some of this work themselves and to make
help us deliver special ed services
better in a cost-efficient way um we
will continue to handle a lot of severe
cases right now we're we're looking at
you know being able to handle and manage
about 1% with those five people of the
IEP cases the IEPs that we have
statewide we have about 30,000 um so so
I would say that if we could get to the
point where we have five people in the
office I'm not going to keep coming back
and asking for more um every couple
Cycles uh the I'd love this committee to
look at what we're not asking for we are
not asking for an office manager we are
not asking for secretaries we're not
asking for legal aids we're not asking
for the pr um line items you know public
relations members that some agencies are
um we we efficiently do a lot of our own
work I do what I had a legal secretary
to do 20 years ago um that's
fine but we do need a few more people to
actually do the work of managing cases
and doing the Data Tracking um and then
you know the last thing I would say is
that we are working systemwide
so we've it it took a while to develop
it was just me for a year and then Tim
joined me and has been you know seven or
eight months um with me Tim jumped right
into the work he has a vast kind of
experience base that complement what I
have
um and we have tried to make sure that
we're relevant um for example later
today I'm meeting with the head of
vocational rehab to say how do we make
those dollars do even better for our
special ed population here's what we're
seeing on the ground in our
casework here are suggestions here are
thoughts I'd love feedback because
ultimately special education is
investment and we need to make sure that
it's actually getting those students to
be productive as productive as they
possibly can be in society and so things
like Voc Rehab vocational rehab that
puts people to work as they come out
School play into that so we are working
systemically um with that I'd love to
turn it over to Tim to talk just a bit
and take questions on the types of cases
and where they're coming from to get to
us
Tim good morning um so a lot of what we
get and is
from
uh
either other agencies that have already
helped people and have imately reach the
stone wall if you will um the office of
the child advocate um they're one floor
down from us so so it's very convenient
um the Department of Education dispute
resolution as well as um there was a
change in their process where whenever a
parent does not agree or signs with
exception they get a letter from doe and
the first name and number on there is us
uh so they it comes direct that happened
this fall and we saw a huge Spike um I
get a lot of referrals on some of the
most catastrophic cases um to use a term
that's been used in the past but um
children that have been out of school a
year and a half two years and they're
all over the state I'm in six counties
right now so there's me in in six
counties um what I will tell you is is
that we're also pointing out things to
to bring better data to the table for
everyone um I when I come across
something rather than point fingers and
say you did this wrong you did this
wrong it's more the we're we're out of
compliance here and we need to move
forward in in an accurate way whatever
that data is it should be accurate so
you can rely on it so the governor can
rely on it and frankly so we know where
to head um to give you you know a
snapshot the IEP process if it's in
has tons of deadlines and notice
requirements weaved throughout it so
there there really is I I would say the
goal is to resolve everything within one
cycle of the IEP and right now we're
doing that we are I I you know 6 months
four months three months those are kind
of my average to get to a solution um
and there when I say a solution these
are ones where people have had the
disabilities rights Center they've had
private Advocates uh I have a woman with
a son who's been out of school for 2 and
A2 years she spent
$225,000 on a private attorney um and
she was fortunate to find one they still
are not at
resolution and it's about finding a
solution um but also about doing it
without this Silo approach of this is
your fault this is your fault we we
actually want to get something effective
done um I have a student who through the
process we discovered that placing her
through a best interest
process um was a better option for her
as a student it actually saved the
school district twice as much money and
it's a better result she's doing well
and I hope to attend her
graduation what where we're really
struggling is we just cannot get to
people fast enough and with all those
timelines ticking it it's very difficult
um I I also have you know dcyf workers
reaching out to me because they've heard
hey you guys solved this impossible
thing and these are the the same
children that that are you know being
placed out of state to the tune of a
half a million dollar a year or more um
and so one of our big pieces is to
really look at can we get those kids
into the appropriate level of
restrictive environment education
there are kids that go to
treatment places that could be attending
public schools at much less cost to
everyone and frankly they're now not
being put in a more restrictive
environment than they need which we know
isn't good for them so that's it's a
holistic approach um I I I literally got
a call from a student services director
at a school district for my assistance
in one of their cases to just be there
for the parent and they're they're on
opposing sides but she thought that our
office could bring some reassurance to
the parent and a solution so it it's
refreshing for me as somebody who's been
in state service a long time to really
be working on how do we solve this the
frustration
is you know I'm in six counties I'm I'm
one
person can't be every where
representative EV and followed by
represent mon you know the The Squeeze
is really General funds so have you
folks thought creatively about other
sources of funds for your program I'll
let you answer that tough question so uh
it it definitely has been suggested um
that there are probably some grants we
could look at um at the federal level
and I would tell you again the question
is really
just who you know a lot of agencies have
a Grant Management person a grant writer
um so so on some level we are just in a
catch 22
of how do we do the work with two of us
um that is a pretty pretty wide
statutory mandate certainly it's
something we could fit into someone's
job description if we can have a few
more stuff right so then just to
understand the the ask here a little bit
better I was trying to figure out what
it would cost for the you were asking
for three three more three additional we
initially in prioritized needs had four
additional cut that down knowing that
it's um a very slim budget season and I
understand that everyone has said you
can't ask for any more than you have
budgeted and I said that's well and good
except that we cannot do and I think
it's it's incumbent on me to say we
can't do the work that the statute is
asking us to do with two of us so three
more people um
you know the we took numbers from
HR um you know from agencies and and
basically I think it built up to
somewhere between 725 and 750,000 your
hand out right and I think we said 750
at the end of that it
says so you you'd be asking for 740
instead of what you've asked for or in
addition um we asked for in the
prioritizes needs something that was
around 850 50,000 so I'm saying we
dropped a position and benefits Etc from
that such that what we're saying now is
740 right so am I reading this right
it's
395 yeah this budget was built without
any you know before the agency existed
without any input um and at some point
the number floated back in 2020 to 2021
was 500,000
that's not you know what it got funded
at before we existed so yes it's a huge
mismatch between you know taking the
budget that we were
given um with a a slight really
basically just salary step increases is
all that does um and saying that that
was never an adequate budget again we
are not asking for Data Systems we are
not ask we're we're not asking for
anything but a few staff to try to
accomplish what it's being asked I I
don't see any rent here do you how do
you have space so we do have space we
have three um rooms in Johnson Hall okay
uh and it it should there there was a
rent line item in there exactly exactly
and that's actually High to be honest
with you in terms of what we're being
build right now like I said we have
three rooms in a one of our older
buildings um it is adequate we're not
asking for more we would figure out how
to trade off um
you know with that stuff but right all
right and let me ask I mean since this
is the two of you what is your um term
in this job is it a threee or is it so
mine was five year five years um okay so
I am a little more than a year and a
half into
that okay and and why are you um a
temporary and not a a regular full-time
class of I I don't know
um I have about 15 years of State
service so they they they told me that
doesn't change so this is temporary with
Benefits though right correct yes yeah I
I I essentially laterally transferred
over I see from DHHS so Jack can we find
out if he we made him
permanent classified would it how would
it affect the budget yeah because it
that seems kind of weird to me all right
uh rep
thank you very much Mr chair thank you
for taking my question I have three
areas I want to look into and I did
watch the live stream last week so I
want to thank you for that um how could
would you describe um the work you do
compared with the parent information
center
um I would say the parent information
center is a very limited first um option
for parents to just learn what it means
you know what rights they have if they
have a child with a disability
um maybe a basic overview of the IEP
process they have sample forms we're not
trying to duplicate any of that it was
one of the biggest things I did when I
came into the role I said there seem to
be a lot of people working in disability
we do not want to be duplicating what
someone else is doing um so we would
refer people to for sample forms and
that kind of thing to the parent
Information Center website um they do
not go to I AP meetings they are not
sort of the find a solution to the
disagreement or the child out of school
or the child
institutionalized um they're not doing
that at all and their trainings fall
short of actual the the actual dispute
resolution process um whereas we Dive
Right In there when we need to um but we
also are doing
um you know I it's really just a Case
Case Management case resolution piece
that gives us a lot more insight I think
through the field work um to school
districts across the state what they're
facing um what parents are fighting we
are good at getting to what the meat of
the question is that can actually be
decided as opposed to all of the emotion
around I you know situations of students
with disabilities okay and um another do
you think the number of cases that come
to your office would be reduced if the
specialed directors in local districts
had more training or experience in
managing special
education and and I'll I'll preface this
by saying I I was on a school board for
nine years and sometimes I see the um
the number of disputes regarding special
education seem to track with the uh
experience or inexperience level of the
director um I was just wondering if
there was does your
office um invest in professional
development of people who are special
education professionals you know program
directors to ensure that resolution can
be attained at the lowest level as
possible without elevating it so it's a
great question um we certainly don't
have really a budget for professional
development but we we do spend staff
time um Tim and I have both done a
number of uh New Hampshire Association
of special ed administrator trainings um
what he alluded to with the placements
when it's by courts or for treatment
episodes and and where the school
districts should participate in that
process is a training he did for special
ed administrators um I've done some
we're trying to roll out even
more uh I'm not sure that the number of
cases coming to our office would be
reduced because really when we're
talking about trying to have staff to
manage a like and bring to resolution
approximately 300 a year that is 1%
of the Statewide I'm not sure we're
going to get that number much lower okay
but we certainly are interested in the
training piece for parents for Advocates
and for special ed administrators and I
have one one more sorry Chris um the
other thing is there are two young men I
know personally who entered educa you
know entered the school system
really without any uh one in fact one
fellow and I spoke on the floor of this
I did a unanimous consent a couple years
ago his parents were told that he would
never speak never be able to be potty
trained and he graduated from college
he's got a great job now in um something
to do with computers computer uh video
design I think and so he's a he's a
taxpaying contributing member of society
and I was wondering is there any uh way
or any attempt to track that kind of
thing because it really does show a
return on investment when you look at
the money that was invested in this
young man's special
education it's I'm sure he's paying a
lot of that back now in at least income
tax so the individuals with disabilities
and Education Act does require states to
report out on indicators and you're
really getting at what you know
indicator 1314
um they have a handful of them um that
talk about the uh next step for people
coming out of the special education
system and and it is precisely getting
it are we are we trading it as an
investment uh doe New Hampshire doe
would tell you again we there's we don't
have robust responses in terms of
numbers on those indicators so while
there is data and you can look at New
Hampshire's indicators for performance
and they look decent um it's not built
on a very large sample so again it goes
back to this data question we really we
need better data across the state for
special education um and and people are
looking at the nitty-gritty of how to
accomplish that but there are indicators
that are supposed to measure precisely
that it's just that we need a more
robust sample of students we are
certainly looking at it in our cases and
saying we need outcomes that I mean it
could range from those were the most
severe disabilities it could be they are
able to participate in an adult Day
program you know through developmental
disability waivers rather than being
institutionalized right that could be
the the positive outcome for the most um
severe or we actually engaged voke rehab
early on we got this student on a job
path even though they were not on a path
to complete a high school diploma I'm
definitely focused and it'll be part of
my conversation today on look at those
students who are on certificate of
completion paths those are not students
going on to a next level of education so
we need to be right in there in that 18
to 22 age 16 to 22
saying let's make sure voke rehab is
actually there for them and I think
there are some changes to that voke
rehab system that you know tweaks that
could get more of those students
involved okay thank you very much
represent
months thank you Mr chairman and um my
apologies for coming in late I was uh
stuck in a phone tree with my health
plan um um and I can just say as the you
know the father of a of a of a as I said
a young man with a developmental
disability he never would have been able
to get through high school had it not
been for the support he received from
the special education department so I
I'm I'm I'm very um supportive of the
work that you're doing um I just want to
try to make sure I understand you know
kind of where you are now and and and
what what you're requesting um so if I
understand correctly right now you've
got you've got two two staff for some
reason one of you is temporary and the
other one's full-time but you've got two
staff um what I'm hearing you say and
what you've put in writing is that um
with that two staff you cannot fulfill
the the the the obligations that we the
legislature and our great wisdom have
imposed on you um and you're looking
looking to hire an additional four staff
right now at this point so that was my
initial request when we did prioritize
needs um we've we've peeled that back to
three okay um really looking at two more
case managers um who would probably
directly report to Tim um and and Tim
and I work very collaboratively together
talking about cases and and and
direction I do handle some myself um the
first year I handled all 40 or 50 that
we resolved myself so pretty close to
them uh so two more case managers and
then we would like to take a position
that's currently funded at um one day a
week uh and combine that with sort of
intake Data Tracking because those are
related right when we bring in a case
getting the data and following through
the resolution assigning that Etc um and
uh policy policy initiative tracking to
say okay with what what's coming in the
door what could we say um and and I that
would be a report directly to me so the
data policy and then two more case
managers is what we're looking for it's
three people so so if you got your wish
list you would end up with five a total
total of five staff and presumably Tim
would become
permanent okay correct all right
thank just to to go back I feel like I'm
being dense here but what you're
actually asking for would you recognize
me
740,000 a year is what you're looking
for that is correct okay thank you sorry
I interjected all right um yeah I
haven't read uh RSA 186c yet but is
your you're not really judicial in the
sense that you have power to decide
cases right you're more of a a
negotiator or something right
to to to try to get people to see things
uh to get them together just by
persuasion is is that right with a with
a tweak to it uh so here is what I would
say the majority of our cases 90% of
them yes that's what we're doing we're
doing it um you know walk softly and
carry a big stick uh our statute does
say that we should ensure that IEP
services are being delivered to students
so uh we do get a number of referrals
quite a few from the Department of Ed in
their dispute resolution and um State
complaint process because what they're
looking for it's their hearing officers
who are the judicial quasi judicial
authorities making decisions they are
looking for us to become involved in
cases with parents sometimes um to say
please help get this case to the best
statement of the issue to be decided so
that our hearing officers can be
effective um so uh they will tell a lot
of parents reach out to the office of
The
Advocate to help you one go to your IP
teams and let's see if we can avoid
dispute resolution but two hone your
case so about 10% of our cases we will
join parents um in an advocate role in
those hearings before doe do you write
an annual report yes we had um a draft
of our first one that we actually had a
ended up
before uh governor sununu and executive
Council in a meeting um with that draft
they asked some questions asked us to
verify some information which I think we
have verified so that is true so we'll
be re posting that first one kind of in
a finalized format yes is the answer
soon right yeah soon yeah yeah okay all
right um great and my last question is
on the budget um there are no funds for
instate travel on um on in 2027 so
that's but you do a fair amount of
instate travel right you want to answer
those question so um I as somebody who's
the traveling Road show a lot of times
uh Park and rides are excellent places
to work from um the first my my mileage
if you will from I live on in in Enfield
to conquered is 60 Mi so I wouldn't be
reimbursed for that if I were to go
because it's within what my daily
commute is so we try to do that as much
as possible I try to do as much virtual
as is
appropriate um with meeting with school
districts and parents but um it all with
an eye on so like hey can we keep that
cost down eventually it it you know
sometimes I'll go to Massachusetts that
happened where I had to go on tours of
schools but it's hard to say with just
two of us that we whether we would need
more for travel or not I see but so in
20 fiscal year 2024 you weren't part of
the agency right so you
um I or were you maybe no not in not in
FY 2024 your will FY 2025 um he started
maybe a couple of weeks before the start
of it um I did a fair amount of travel I
did the same thing Tim does um would go
from home out a certain way as opposed
to coming into the office do we need
zero budget for travel no we need some
budget for instate travel if for being
fair to ourselves which often we are
probably not um it was not a priority
and I think there were a lot of moves
you know uh between my argument for
prioritized needs which were hundreds of
thousands over where we were and you
know right now I don't even know if the
budget really adequately pays our
salaries or has kind of Step increases
is I'm I'm getting reports that we're
going to go over on some of our salary
items um from Daz and I think I I'm not
sure what to say right for fiscal year
25 right yes no but I just meant I just
want this to be accurate right so we
need a bit there you know um at the
moment you know it's it's small enough
dollars and even with two more case
managers it's probably small enough
dollars because we are not sending
people needlessly
off everywhere um that it could be
reclassed from kind of the you know what
is still a very small amount but sort of
some general line items we do not buy
much if anything all right any further
questions representative Lehman followed
by representative evil thank you Mr
chairman I'm assuming you did the same
presentation with the governor or the
budget director and I'm just curious why
she or they didn't support your request
for the $740,000
um so I I say we we did do the request
um in the earlier phase when the uh
Governor had the budget hearings um
neither Governor snono nor Governor aat
were there when we spoke about that we
have submitted it a few different times
um my understanding is it is just the
very tight budget cycle and an agency
asking for a budget that's double what
it has doesn't fly um we didn't have
cuts we had a marginal increase which
would just do kind of our step salary
increases um beyond that I would say
that with the agency being as new as it
is um people don't necessarily know well
what we do and it that did come out
before the governor and executive
Council in December when we were
discussing um what we do there were a
lot of questions about why couldn't we
just refer all our cases
on to someone else and there were
parents who were pretty indignant um
we've had quotes from area agencies who
say I really hope you all can survive
and can continue to do what you're doing
because we're referring to you when no
one else has gotten it done so I I would
say being a new agency it's not well
understood what we do is my best answer
represent
V thank you um would you say that if you
were better funded new Hampshire's
special education dollars would be more
effectively
spent I hope so I think I would say that
I think we um are about to invest a
large amount of money in special
education I saw the number and and
having um oversight there and looking
for efficiencies where it's possible
can't do anything but help
okay we we've been collaborative with
Department of Ed um whereas some
agencies who are who are independent and
in somewhat of an oversight position are
not collaborative with with those
agencies that maybe they're doing
oversight we've also been collaborative
with school districts so I think people
trust us to say look we we have to look
at efficiency as well as looking at
what's best for an individual case we're
representing and we're committed to
doing that we've been asked um to
participate both in labor costing
efforts and building out Data Systems
within doe and we've been asked to
participate in a suggested I don't know
if it will go through but uh um right
now I believe there's going to be a
build this session about um commissions
to study the costs of special education
and various Solutions and and we've been
listed in that and so I think that
people trust us to try to be conscious
of the efficiency of dollars and then
the other one I I'm wandering into
terrain I'm not familiar with and I hope
don't get struck by lightning by asking
this question but is it conceivable that
your group could be paid for through the
education trust fund or does that give
you the heie
jeebies yeah well okay so I'll answer
this question because basically from the
point of view of the budget there is no
difference right so so there's no
practical difference doing one way or
the other um I think in general we're
trying to keep the keep the education
trust fund for adequate Ed and take out
all of the this that and the other thing
that's that has been in there in the
past is is that right representative W
okay so so the answer is probably not
but but but at the end of the day it it
really doesn't matter when you know
one's the left pocket and the other's
the right pocket kind of thing I guess
that's right it's just that one is very
restricted and the other can be used
okay in many ways so that's why I asked
the question but if I could add anything
to that even as the special education
Advocate I am concerned with I'm very
interested to see what happens with
funding bills with the education trust
fund Etc because I don't want to see um
the tensions that currently exist
between special education and general
education one of the efficiencies that
I've suggested is that we really need to
look at you know the 25,000 or so out of
the 32,00 population and
say are some can some of those be on
IEPs for short periods of time and then
come off to the multi-tiered systems of
support obviously less restrictive that
should be there in gen Ed but if we're
making trade-offs between special
education and general education at the
local levels they're more likely not to
have the same level of multi-tiered
systems of support that benefit all
students so I don't I don't want to see
those trade-offs I want to see what we
can do to get to a better place than
where we are right now in that okay all
right well thank you very much for
coming I I really appreciate it um we'll
let you go back to your case loan thank
you yeah so for the committee um so
we're going to come back and be with the
treasure at
115 um after that I'd like to you know
we'll have seen everybody basically so I
want to uh hand out some things and talk
about the big picture and then I wanted
to spend if we if I don't know what if
representative Sweeney is coming back
but I wanted to spend the rest of the
afternoon in caucus and and sort of talk
about um kind of where we're going and
our targets and things like that so um
that's kind of my plan for the rest of
the today any questions no no we're
happy okay good thank
you
e
e e
uh treasur
Mell
yeah I know our whole discussion was
kind of cut cut off last time and we
have a couple people back that weren't
here so um good
afternoon good so uh we already asked
about on this page you you're adding a
person so that's uh an entry-level
accountant that is correct
um and oh how about vacancies do we ask
about that there aren't any I think I do
not have vacancies right now yeah okay
hope hope it stays
our um
okay and we asked
about what happened to other funds in
fiscal year
25 and I don't
remember what was the answer to that one
oh the funds Rel relative to on page
152 expenditure total for the treasury
Department right everything looks sort
of normal except for fiscal year
right because other funds went from 160
to 30 oh that was it the um rooms of
meals wasn't correct budgeted it wasn't
part of the budget now it is and now
it's back again it's back yes but it was
part for part of the year or part of the
bium or something yeah it wasn't
included in the budget initially but the
expenditures um were recorded in the
accounting unit where the activity
happens it's just it wasn't in the in
the
um original bad budget I see what you're
saying so if I looked at what we passed
two years ago it would have had 35 comma
35 or something like that is that right
but when it became actual now there's
the number there correct yeah yeah yeah
I see okay
good okay so that explained that
one
um page
138 we'll go back to the beginning here
okay
[Music]
so this accounting
un right so you move people around I
guess this this accounting unit is
getting four more people from somewhere
else that is correct we we moved them
from other Divi other divisions so they
can
um reconcil in the unit reconciliation
unit in anticipation of the changes that
are coming with the accounting
system right okay
good
um okay we talked a bit
about um is cheated property on page
140 oh again because this is an actual
that is an amount that is typically not
right so that's that's that's not
budgeted because we don't know how much
we're going to return but those are
funds that come from the general fund uh
because we always um we always will will
return property um even after the funds
are cheated to the general fund okay
so is this the one we had the question
of whether um Ways and Means numbers for
the general fund had this income and
this expense it is but so so the activ
the cheated U portion what we return the
property we return gets recorded there
but your question I think it was
relative to um some expenditures that
happen in the abandom property Division
and that was related to the uh external
audits that we do to um uh the
Multistate audits um we have contracts
with
uh firms that go out that go out and do
Multistate Audits and we have budgeted
an amount that you were trying to see if
that was um oh yeah uh an amount page
147 I think 147 that's correct and um we
looked at so we typically budget a a an
amount that is going to allow us to pay
um we don't know how many of those firms
are going to come back and say well we
we found all this property um and once
they remit that property to us is when
we pay them about 10% of of that a
contingency fee um so we we usually
budget an amand that will allow us we
don't know how much that's going to be
so we looked at some history and there
were years that we pay 700,000 less than
that um so we typically just we we like
to have a a a number that we don't have
to go to fiscal in case we we we have to
pay that um what I will say what I will
add to that is regardless of how much we
budget here whatever we spend the actual
is what gets um taken from this
achievment the G to J fund so and and
the ex the estimate that we provide to
way and means has other variables um so
so it really won't impact the revenue
number even if we change this number
here I see what we're talking about by
the way just for everybody else is on
page 147 the very first number the
current expense
I think that's
why so yes so you notice the actual is
500,000 but but the budgeted amount is
1.5 million and so but what she's saying
is that will become an actual at some
point and it's all figured in because
basically um you have this expense of
this 500,000 you have the expense of the
4 and a half million on page 140 so
there's a total expense of this thing of
five million but the amount of property
that gets abandoned is like 24 million
or something so what actually ends up in
the general fund is is1 million or
something like that right that is
correct okay and but it's all included
in what we already know from or it's
estimated in what we know from ways of
means
so there's nothing nothing to see here I
guess is no unfortunately I don't I
don't have any anything else to to to
change that estimate the revenue
estimate is is what we expect and
hopefully that's what we get right quick
quick question go ahead r% of months
yeah thank you thanks for coming in I'm
sorry I missed your presentation last
week so I'm playing a little bit of
catchup sure um so did I hear correctly
that we that we have $24 million a year
of abandoned property Revenue that comes
in into the general fund so it has been
increasing over the last few years but I
will say about 20 million we collect um
again has been increasing so last over
the last few years we have we have
collected about 23 24 million we try to
return as much as we can so last year
was a high year we returned 12 million
um and this year I think we're we're not
we're not as high but again we Tred to
return so whatever we don't return after
3 years um and we pay our expenditures
here our expenses we we we Che to the
general fund so that becomes un
restrictive Revenue to the general fund
I think I think you answered one of my
questions then was because I see the ads
that are running on TV now about you
know abandoned property which I need to
follow up on myself sure um but um so
the only money that goes back to the
general fund is money that has kind of
gone through that threeyear kind of
waiting period if you will that is
correct so so that's what the law says
if we don't if we're don't return after
three years we has cheated however um
the owners of the property can come back
at any time and that's the other line
that you see um on page I can't remember
what page it was but that's the amount
that we have returned after um after we
ex cheated those funds to to the general
fund so a a property owner can always
come back to us and collect their funds
which which line is is that the the 1.5
million or is that the 4
million that is um is cheetah property
and that's
page 140
maybe Sly yes
140 so last year we returned 4.4 million
this 24 you don't see anything in 25 but
um I think we have um I think we have
returned about 2 million this year
something around that yeah um yes uh
representative Ron quick question thank
you so much um for coming and I am sorry
I missed your presentation last week but
I I know in the um the union leader
prints that all the aband what other
ways do we reach out to the public to
see if just to let them know that there
may be abandoned property so that's what
that's one way and that's in the law we
have we we we publish um the list and un
leader all of the pro all of the new
properties that we collect that's that's
the list that that you see on the unit
leader so the other way we do this so we
just tried that um that ad for the first
time we wanted to try it we we never
really had the bandwidth of the of the
staff to be able to um to do that but we
tried that this year that was it it
looks like it's successful we wanted to
start low not you know not to um we
wanted to just again try it but the
other way we do it is we do our reach
events we try to um um we ask uh
organizations if they can invite us for
the day and so we go and we we we go for
the day we just attended a nursing home
in ASA um so different places to to try
to return those funds um at the national
level the the organizations that we
belong to the um National um National
Association of State treasurers that
help us at the national level so we've
had um we've had um whenever good
morning in America talks about abandoned
property then we get this all of this
new Quest so um so there are different
ways that we try to return it but again
we're trying to explore a few more of
those options to try to return it uh
throughout the
year yes do you list it on your website
as well yes it's okay it's all there
it's all on the website yes do you know
how many let's say from the union lyrics
that must be pretty costly to run that
print and what what is the cost and how
many uh inquiries do you get from that
do you believe it's cost effective it is
expensive there is no doubt I mean um it
isn't the law that's the reason we we we
do it uh it needs to be a publication
that um with Statewide circulation so
that's a union leader um we we I haven't
tried to change that just because it is
again that's that all of the states do
it that way but also we're just trying
to increase the reach um and different
ways um is it cause effective I I just I
don't want to take the business from the
leader yet there's I think we can find
all the ways and and again we we
continue to collect more property every
year um and so I think we just need to
um again continue that effort chair can
I just follow up on that question um so
where where in the budget is is the are
those expenses the uh expenses for the
ads in the union leader yes so that's
that's
um this again as some patient one
I'm lost
again uh
47 yes so um the activ all of the
expenses of the division the V and
property division at start in um on page
147 and
48 so it will be um Publications will be
on 20 close 20
oh no it is it is 20 it will be in CL 20
current
expenses so so and I'm sure that that
that that cost center probably includes
some other items in addition to the the
current expenses includes the majority
of the money is um is what we pay to the
the firms the AUD firms that I was
mentioning we have contracts with them
we have we have about 10 contracts so
essentially we do we do business with
all of the other firms that um are in
that industry yep just so we can uh
collect as much property as possible
what I'm trying to get a handle on is
the the the amount that's actually being
spent or budgeted for placing ads in the
paper do you Rec or 30,000 how much 25
or 30,000 I was hoping there'd be a few
more
zeros okay
and I can we can confirm that amount
still significant okay um yeah and just
for the
interest this abandoned property it
doesn't just sit here for three years
it's already sat you know in some
broker's account or something for 10
years or something like that and then we
get it and then we sit on it another a
some number of years right
so this is not you know
anyway it it comes it's been sitting for
a long period of time okay and that's
why so many people don't come back and
get it because maybe they're not around
all right so page 144 I just
um I guess we asked about um the
university so so we pay debt back and
there's there it's it's in a number of
different groups so our main debt
payments
um are on page
143 um Debt Service right
um looks like
uh going up to 68 million in 20 do we
ask why oh um you said the reason
that um fiscal year 26 and 27 or so
different was the prison is that that is
correct and I recalculated that um The
Debt Service for for that fiscal year so
I had an opportunity to speak with um
the commissioner departmental
Corrections and um again we're not
planning on bonding it this year so
that's why you don't see it in FIS year
26 The Debt Service but um but there's
an expectation that they're spending the
money over the next um couple of years
so we will be bonding that amount what I
was able to confirm with the
commissioner is that they'll spend the
40 million
not at once they'll spend it over time
over the period of two years so with
that information what I did is I
recalculated that Debt Service assuming
that we will issue 20 million and 20
million in two different years rather
than one so I have those numbers um that
I can provide dlba if you um I believe
that would be more a more accurate Debt
Service to use uh and that way 27 won't
be as High um but 28 will be higher or
is it oh yes future years will be higher
for
TR okay good I have that information so
yeah but 26 won't change 26 won't change
so why was
26 oh so 25 adjusted authorized may not
be accurate either right it might end up
being less
than fiscal the current fiscal
year
um this should be accurate the 60 64 and
a
half
yes okay so why is the surrounding year
is
less what made that year high I'm 143
14 you see where it says Debt
Service so for the most part Debt
Service declines we we we pay more than
what we borrow but there are times that
those N I can't remember if there was
anything in particular that made that um
budget number higher however if we
didn't spend all the 64 which is very po
I think we have an expectation we will
lapse do you recall that amount I don't
okay we can get that number but it's not
it's not going to be the 64 million
total we're going to lapse an amount um
60 fisc year
um we include assumtion assumption that
we're bonding so when we start bonding
you you you see the debt the the debt
Services reflected the following year so
in 26 we so for example this year we're
going to bond approximately 16 million
and that's why the The Debt Service in
26 is lower in 27 we're increasing The
Debt Service we are we are assuming
we're going to issue more bonds and just
simply because even the capital budget
right now has uh uh um the governor's
proposal includes 140 million for the
bium so that alone is 70 million each
year and then we're adding the 20
million so that number is going to uh be
what I have here is that it's going to
be 66 million
66.9 rather than 68 that you see here I
actually heard from the chair of Public
Works and he thinks they're not going to
do more than 120 five okay so you know
that might come down again a little bit
so again what we don't spend we lapse
and typically it
in for the most part that that's a
that's a number we use but sometimes we
we don't end up issuing the 60 million
it's just an estimate it's just over the
years that's that's about the average 60
million in bonds but again we Bond based
on the expenditure so if the agencies
are not spending fast enough we don't
have to bond the entire amount so some
sometimes that's what we end up lapsing
representative M thank you uh and again
forgive me for uh if I'm asking a
question that um may have already been
answered um so the just looking at fy2
24 the $59
million that is The Debt Service on all
of the debt that the state of New
Hampshire has outstanding all of or is
there is there are there any debts that
are kind of off the books yes well
there's future there's more pages we're
going to get to in a moment so this 59
million is is debt paid with General
funds so anything that is budgeted and
there is not um is not debt that is
going to be repay with other revenue for
example The Liquor Commission if they if
they if they have a project they pay
with liquor funds uh so if there are
some agencies that have other funds they
pay uh they pay their debt with those
those funds funds so this number 59
million is just um is is debt repay with
General funds and where and and if if
the if like the liquor uh commission has
debt um The Debt Service on that debt
does that show up in your budget or show
up in their budget their budget there's
um so the the other dat that you'll see
uh represent my wi was mentioning is um
the university system is another it's
it's it's separate but it's also paid
with General funds the university system
and then we have debt the community
college system The Debt Service that you
see there that is paid by the Community
College by the system in school build
and Aid is repaid with the meals and
rooms um tax so that's considered all
the revenue not general fund so you'll
see that on the following
Pages yeah so go to page we'll Turn the
Page to 144
so some of our debt is on behalf of the
University system and it's just called
out for whatever reason in this
particular accounting
unit um and it these numbers assume that
that we're going to borrow roughly $10
million a
year every year for
them but um anyway and the other and
these are all General funds and the
other accounting units that you see is
again Debt Service for the community C
system they're paying their debt it's
just because of the way the capital
budget was was um adopted that way and
and then we also have
um School building Aid right so that's
interesting School building AIDS
straight out of rooms and meals that's
how it was uh yes that's how this um
this Bonds were were yeah authorized to
be repay with a portion of the meals and
rs tax okay representative people is
that statutory or was that yes yeah
yes but this is probably just the tale
of we we haven't given new school
building Aid in a while I think that's
correct that we have four more years
there for of this number but it's uh we
have um
I say 15 million outstanding I believe
just make a comment yes so I was just
going to say on the UNH thing I mean
Peter's been here sorry Peter longer
than any of us but there used to be a
keep program for UNH where they were and
so maybe what was it like for 10 years
or something they were guaranteeing that
they were going to add Capital monies
for un every banian for to help them
catch up so it may be because of the
program that they have a separate line I
don't know there's a separate line
because at some point the the governor's
um the budget office they they wanted to
have a separate accounting unit for that
to track their Debt Service but but
every year um there's there's an
authorization for UNH to be repay with
General funds so um even this budget the
current the governor's budget has a
proposal for 10 for 20 million in
total right rep representative months
um and let me just preface what I'm
going about to say with you know I'm not
necessarily recommending this but I'm
just kind of curious um are are there
are there opportunities or is there any
prevent is there anything
preventing you us from restructuring the
debt to maybe lessen the burden now
and and and either either take advantage
of lower interest rates which is
probably not the case because they're
going up but to restructure the debt to
to maybe help us in the short term and
give us a little bit of breathing room
going forward trust me she's already
done it thank you for the question um so
uh every time we issue bonds we look at
the possibility of doing refunding so if
those bonds are cable so after 10 years
we have the opportunity to to to look at
those bonds and and if they're callable
we look at we look at those bonds to see
if there is a possibility to to refund
them and because because of lower rates
or because the coupons right now are are
are again if it's economically
beneficial for the state we look at that
so we're about to issue bonds and right
now we're we're considering to refund in
approximately $80 million in bonds those
bonds are accable um if the economics
work the day of the sale we will proceed
with with refunding those bonds if we
don't look that's that's beneficial for
the stay we stop and we wait until the
next opportunity or we just keep paying
so that's that's what we do every time
we do analysis of those those bonds that
we can try to take advantage of the
market conditions go ahead if you were
to if you were to re to to to refinance
that that 80 million for
example and I know it's it's hard to to
estimate but is there any do you have
any sense at all what that might do in
terms of extra cost or well lower cost
to the state you know in the in the next
two years so so what I can say about the
ones that we're looking at right now
those 80 million we we bring We'll um
right now they they look like they will
provide um
approximately um like $2 million net
present value of savings of $2 million
so so we look at so if it's
so um Net Present Value so it will be
you will see you will see those savings
over the um next 10 years but the
present value is about 2 million um we
typically um the way we we we the way we
analyze that if it's going to provide
about more than 3% of
savings uh of the refunded bonds that's
what we think is economically beneficial
for the state if it's less than that it
doesn't make sense the costs are too
high and and we can just wait until the
next opportunity if there is one
okay representative evil um Mr chair I
did request from the treasurer the debt
affordability study and that I forwarded
to everybody and I did want to ask just
a couple go ah is this appropriate time
okay um well first of all I I wish that
the
finance got copies of this and we could
talk a little bit more about it here
because we I know being a public works
geek
uh we talked about this at Great length
in the capital budget but you know
obviously in finance this is where we're
seeing the effect of the bonding so I
just wondered if I mean it it looks like
we're doing well in this document um any
if you want to say anything on that but
I just I guess where I'm going with this
is we have um we have the potential
liability from the YDC cases there are
some other things that might be clouds
on the horizon as far as our bond rating
and our overall fiscal health and I I
just this is such a good snapshot of
where we are
Statewide i' i' kind of like to open it
up to you a little bit to let you talk
to ask you to discuss this and if you
see any um flashing signs of
concern thank you representative uh
just just for your information we we did
share the study with I think we we get
we we went went distribute that the LBA
gets a copy and we post it on the
website but I'll be happy to to share it
even more I did share what you sent me
yes mean we don't talk about he that
much sure um so yes you're correct the
the study uh shows that the current
conditions of the state essentially the
Deb profile that we have is is is
positive the um the red um the debt to
revener ratio which a is a key metric
that we review that's that's
3.8% um it has has decreased over time
um because of the and that's primarily
driven by the revenues the performance
of revenues over the last few years so
that's you can still have that you can
still see that that the ratio is last
year was 4% this year is
3.8% um but the key of that is again
revenues have have performed but also uh
the policies relative to Debt Service to
to issue in debt so if we continue to
issue debt of approximately 60 million
each year again we will continue to
issue that and and and and and pay what
we and we usually pay um 60% of
principle during the first um 10 years
and then 40 during the last 10 years
what that does is it has is has we we
use a rapid U repayment um structure
that allows us to continue to have a
healthy um debt profile so again all of
those uh different policies that we have
implemented over time the state has
implemented over over time um the fact
that the legislature stays within the
120 million
125 million each bium that allows us to
to to have a more predictable um
um again amount of debt that we have
outstanding the revenues are difficult
to predict so that's what we like to uh
maintain our our our debt in a way that
is manageable um so that's what I can
essentially that's what this study does
and then what we do with this study is
we also try to project and we use
several assumptions um the some of them
don't don't are are not you know perhaps
this sum around are not going to be U
working as well but we we assume that
we're going to issue again approximately
60 million in bonds we made some
assumptions revenues were going to
increase there's another scenario there
that we used um revenues were flat so I
think that's probably more likely that
that's that's a more um appropriate
scenario to review but but when you look
at those R so what we do is we try to
analyze what the how the ratios are
going to perform over time so with that
scenario and this study uh you'll see
that this the the ratios continue to be
manageable so that's what we want to
look at the revenue the the rating
agencies worry about um that metric
increasing too much if we're close we're
in the 8% 10% will be really bad we
probably have a downgrade so so the
rating indenes will start worry if our
if our if we start issuing too much debt
our revenues are not performing that
means those metrics are going to start
being not as positive and so that's when
they will Pro put us in some type of
negative outlook now you just mentioned
other things that are going on one of
the things that is considered credit
positive is the way we manage our debt
so there are other things that are
coming like the whatc claims and and
other budgetary pressure pressures um
the rating agenes are going to look at
that they're going to look at the amount
of um the amount of reserves that we
have so this year it looks like we're
have a projected deficit um so depending
on how much we take from the rainy day
fund they want they're going to want to
see what we're going to do over the next
few years to replenish those funds so
again it's a whole picture the way we
manage our debt is one of the probably
easiest way to manage our our our uh
finances uh the other you know again the
other aspects of the of our finances are
a little more um um challenging I will
say especially when we want to maintain
our revenues um you know flat or or
um again we just have to produce a
balanced budget so I know it can be
challenging but representative evil yeah
so I mean basically uh what we have in
our rainy day fund is a factor that the
rating and and of course with the rating
agencies uh their opinion on things
helps with the salability of our bonds
right and the interest rat so it's all
like sort of relevant so what we so
we've been building up our rainy day
funds but now there's a propos proposal
on the table uh to take 81 million out
right um so I mean I'm asking the
question also because in the governor's
budget she didn't put this time um
anything for the prison whereas last
time and there's nothing in the capital
budget so you know we're talking a lot
about what to do about that so that's
that would be on top of if if you know
we just do the 120 potential of another
40 if people and then we have the
looming issue of the of the YDC I mean
that's the only other big looming thing
I see out there and that's just not
anywhere in the budget at this point so
just knowing from my experience with the
capital budget and this debt I mean it
all hangs together right yeah yes and
what I will add is
um the so we have calls with r agencies
next week actually and the I what the
questions that will comment and I'm
positive about this is what is the state
planning like what is what is going to
be the plan for the YDC uh even if it
takes 10 years to to to to cover that
what is the plan um you know what is the
plan for the rainy day fund they just
obviously depending on the answers that
I provide that's how they're going to
see okay let taking Montana stable
Outlook anything that they hear that is
is um not favorable obviously they can
put us on a watch so uh it's very
important obviously the work that you're
doing to understand all of the pieces
and and you absolutely correct if our
ratings are um if we maintain the
highest ratings our borrowing costs are
going to be uh low and and they're going
to be uh again more investors are going
to want to buy our bonds and and again
that um lowers a cost and just and so
the revenue picture is also part of that
right yes and our revenues have been
okay absolutely the revenues have been
not performing as well so one of the
things they look at they they look at is
how diverse our revenues are so for
example if the business um business
taxes are now working this this year or
you know currently they obviously is
important to maintain a different type
of Revenue that could provide in
different times uh again having uh
diversity is important um so yes so we
should add gambling is that what you're
saying I heard that
what start divers all right anyways okay
um let's keep keep going thank you yes
um page
148 so this is something else I think we
did talk about this last time
um what you can see toward the bottom of
the page this is the uh money from the
Fidelity 50 529
plans um and which is given out in Grant
in um scholarships I guess yes um and I
think we asked I don't know if we asked
what was what's the why is it going up 5
million per year from the actual to the
budgeted number so um fiscal year 24 was
a a a year um I will say that the the
commission um that oversees this program
was trying to send less money to the um
endowments and more uh funds to students
directly through uh direct scholarships
and we're trying to find our balance um
there was a period of time that um it
wasn't the the commission didn't reach
the target we um we're trying to
disperse as much money as possible so
that was a year that is wasn't um the
criteria utiliz for the scholarships uh
we weren't able to send um
um give out as much as as many
scholarships as as we wanted um FIS year
26 though and 27 is it looks like we
were going to be able to provide more
scholarships to students um based on um
colleges universities provide provide us
with estimates of um their eligible
students we looked at that um last
December and it looks like we're going
to um be able to help more students um
over the next couple of or next year and
going
forward and um so again you you can't
really see that because we we tried to
budget um what
we essentially we're trying to spend all
of the money the fact that 24 didn't uh
it didn't work out uh was an anomaly um
in 26 again we tried to budget all of
the funds that we anticipate collecting
from uh from Fidelity um hopefully we're
able to spend that money I think that's
what that's did some of the 24 money
laps in some way or or is it still go
back into the trust fund for future for
future expenditure for future grants so
so these 26 and 27 numbers are bigger
than what's actually coming from
Fidelity because we're going to use some
of this trust fund money or not or you
talking about the education trust fund
no this is uh this this is a trust um is
is called the New Hampshire excellence
and higher education trust fund okay the
money that comes from um from Fidelity
is deposit in that fund and is used um
for two scholarship programs right um so
if not all of the funds are spent then
it goes back into the trust fund for
future use um the I guess one thing I'm
going to add um the
funds FIS year 26 funds are already
students already know is we we notify
colleges universities that they were
going to receive this funds they already
are preparing the um fin financial aid
packaging including all of those funds
for students so um we do anticipate
spending this amount and perhaps more
from the trust fund I see so it does
have a very healthy balance here he does
yeah okay right so I just tell the
um uh tell the committee this is
something that division 2 is aware of
and and may be making changes in this
area so even though it looks sort of
like it's on our side it isn't
really
um again the only thing I will add to
that is essentially funds for FIS year
26 have been promised to students just
want to keep that in mind yeah yeah
right exactly they might
need right but anyways but there's
Revenue also right so yeah um okay um so
what what was just handed out was uh
whole bunch of dedicated funds that are
all uh controlled by the treasury so so
it gets you some some
information about that um one of the
most interesting is on page
163 so uh the Japanese government gave
us $110,000 in
1905 and we now have
$216,000 in this account
so um that's for the Japanese not
oh support program it's it's because we
they had um a a peace treaty negotiated
in Portsmouth I guess with with uh
Russia and um they this was the gift for
the Japanese as a result so 120 years
ago well I think they did some yeah
anyways so um I I'm actually on the El
chip board and um so they just went
through they go through an annual Grant
run round and they spend the maximal
amount of money every time and
so I believe all they really have left
is at this point is
$600,000 something I mean yeah they they
make all these grants it's a very I mean
you guys know it's a very competitive
program and they they uh leave no money
on the
table it's interesting to see how the
real estate business has dropped off
right because
much more Revenue came in 2122 than in
23 24 I mean it's really dependent on on
real estate sales but um I was trying to
remember maybe last year they had
applications twice as much as the money
they had to give out so it's a very
competitive program and as I say they're
not ones to sit on the money it goes out
the door
annually okay all right good let's keep
going here
all right so that answers that question
there's actually about I'm sorry Mr go
ahead there's something about the Ben
Thomson trust fund I think in hb2 yes
yes and I can speak and I can speak to
that um so we we are
um we had a discussion with the univers
university system to try to um move the
right now by law I need to have custody
of of the of the trust fund and the
conversation that we were having is um
the possibility of transferring that
trust to uh the UNH Foundation
essentially they will um they
will um essentially they will do the
same the same um they are the
beneficiaries uh University of New
Hampshire is the beneficiary so they
will um add the trust fund to um um
again it will be over overseeing the way
they they they do their um their
endowments so um what we are so house
will too the what we are what we need to
do in order for that to happen is we
need to repeal all of the laws um
relative to the Ben Thompson trust fund
um that says that we the treasury needs
to have C the treasurer needs to have
custody of that fund and at the same
time we will be working with the
Department of Justice to try to change
the
purpose of of
um
um I guess the trust um and it will be I
guess the court will will have to
um make the decision to be able to
transfer all of the funds to the um
University of New Hampshire foundation
so we will have to again um repealing
the loss is one step the other step is
is work with Department of Justice to be
able to change that purpose and and and
for the uh un Foundation to have those
funds um so that's why it's in house
bill to
um it was um so again the university
system is interested in having those
funds um they will do a wonderful job
managing it um what what is happening
right now is what we sent to um the
University of New Hampshire is what was
established in the laws of
1909 I believe that says we need to send
a quy payment
to um UNH and that's the amount that is
in the law so we have to either
so regardless of the path we follow the
law needs to be again the whole
situation needs to be re-evaluated to
really understand how much the
University of New Hampshire should
receive from this from this trust um
$331,000 is is probably not the right
amount at this time so again um the pth
that we're following is working with
Department of Justice to change to to
change the custody move it to the
University of New Hampshire Foundation
um but again step one is to one of the
steps is to repeal these laws and why um
our expenses double this this uh
payment is that expenses for managing
the fund is there in there I believe
this are indirect cost right is that the
indirect cost is what we see here the
125 yes and there a cost 100 that's what
it
is and so the expenditure says what we
sent the um
un right but it in the in the
description it says you're sending you
an H
32,000 but the expenses are
62,000 it's 31 30 31 887 correct that's
that's I'm an engineer so that's 32,000
you see yes I believe that's the amount
I'm not I'm not sure
where right so the question is but you
see in the table right expenses
62,64 oh you're looking at this details
oh right right so these expenses are the
the management of the fund the the
investment fees okay so that's my point
is half of this is going to TD
Bank is and only half is going to the
university that is correct so the amount
that's going to the university is is not
correct it's just the amount that has
been it's been sent for decades this is
why we're reviewing that fund but again
the path that we're following right now
is to try to move those funds from our
custody to the University of New
Hampshire um again that that's the based
on conversations that's what everyone is
interested in doing so Mr chair so so
the idea is rather than you managing the
fund it would be the university that's
correct I mean we we don't have a
problem managing the fund but but again
we just need to um we just need to
review how much money the University of
Ni Hampshire should receive and that was
again that could be that path that we
followed perhaps that's what the core
decides um so that's what's being
reviewed right now yeah and it's not
like they're doing a bad job I mean you
look at other sources that's the revenue
right that's the inv the investment
income right and those are not bad
numbers really
correct okay yeah CU that's right here
but it's just uh
anyway okay very
good
so uh let's go to
page 149 at the very
bottom um what is the governor's
scholarship fund yes
that is a scholarship program also
overseen by the college tuition Savings
Plan advisory
commission and that is a program that's
a that's a that's a scholarship program
funded with General
funds um just for the heck of it or yeah
yes um and it just adds to what we're
getting from Fidelity to so there are
two different programs and there two
different programs um when we were
putting the budget together I did ask
the governor's office if they were
interested in funding the program and
they wanted to fund it so that's what
you see here okay I mean it looks like
they even added a million or something
is that so typically we've been
receiving about $3
million um since this program was um
established $3 million each year to fund
this program
there are um this is a program that is
being reviewed just because the way this
this this the eligibility and the
law uh we're not finding enough students
that qualify for that so but in the
meantime right there's a there's a
there's a balance here if you look at
the um dedicated funds report you use we
have a is there a special fund for this
balance of about 14 million that those
million approximately half is restricted
the other one is is available um the
restricted portion is is because the way
this program works is when those
scholarships are awarded um they are
spent over a period of four years
they're now all spent in the first year
so the awards are foure Awards and we
need to wait until they're all spent but
then we've been able to to award funds
every year um but again so we have to
mark on a restricted portion of of that
amount but right now it we have about
$10 million available unrestricted for
that fund just because um they're not
enough students to um that have been
eligible for that program so so why
don't we see the 2.7 from the general
fund coming into this fund
well it is it is about if you look at
expenditures of 24 about 2.3 million in
expenses yes that's how much we've been
able to disperse every
year right so what we see under other
sources that's the general
fund all
sources
yes that's correct and what we see under
Revenue that's the in the investment
income correct gotcha okay so it's a
little backwards from the other one the
other page we
saw
okay okay this is General okay very
good yes represent R thank you Mr chair
so um on the governor scholarship fund
you said that not it's not fully
dispersed to the goals because not
enough students are eligible for it is
there a possibility of raising the
scholarship for those that are eligible
because College expenses have gone up I
don't know how long we've had that
$2,000 a year award so so that program I
believe was established in 2018 and um
the eligibility criteria is in the is is
um included in the law so it needs to be
the student is to be palale eligible
full-time
student um and they receive and and if
the student is
um receives the the uh New Hampshire
scholar designation the student receives
$2,000 if the student who qualifies
doesn't have the designation the student
receives
$1,000 um the rules uh made that program
a little more complicated because the
student needs to be continuously
enrolled in an institution so if a
full-time student decides to um skip a
semester then automatically they lose um
that scholarship that Grant um so again
it's just the the structure of how this
fund was designed um the commission is
is very interested in reviewing um the
three programs that they're overseeing
now and and try to see if there's a
better way to disperse all of the
funds okay go ahead so if a student
receives a scol scholarship but then
decides for some reason or another not
to return to school for a semester do
they think does it pick up if they do
return or does it forever it's gone it's
whever gone for us
student all right yes go ahead thank you
Mr chair uh can a student apply if
theyve they're already in college and
they didn't know about this program and
they're already a sophomore junior can
they can they apply at that point no it
has to be full-time student completing
High School
um full-time completing high school so
it's a little bit limited and I believe
the purpose of the program was to
encourage um full-time enrollment and so
students can
um uh again um start uh a college
education and stay there receive these
grants and essentially start in the
workforce right away so it's a different
type of program with intention to
promote um you know not enrolling
part-time and taking years to to
complete because um there are studies
that show if some students are part-time
sometimes they don't complete the
courses they get student loans and it
just becomes more expensive so the idea
of this program was to try to help these
students to join the workforce as soon
as possible and is the program well
publicized within the school system and
you know C counselors teachers do they
know of this
program I'm not clear I think I my
opinion I think um schools could
probably do a better job promoting this
program but but again I'm not I'm not
really clear this this is we hold the
funds and and and colleges universities
are responsible for promoting the
programs and um there's more that
probably the treasury can do and those
are the those are the thoughts we've had
to to be able to promote this programs
in the future more um one of our goals
too thank my pleasure okay
um go ahead represent thank you thank
you Mr chair uh so you mentioned that
this scholarship fund is overseen is by
the New Hampshire College tuition
Savings Plan advisory commission can you
tell me more about that i' I'm not
familiar with it yes um so I also serve
on that commission and this is the
commission that oversees the fight and R
plan as well and um so it's a it's um
Commission made up of 13 members uh
there are members uh of
the um there are two public members um
members of the um higher um higher
education uh industry um the chancellor
of the University of system Chancellor
of the community college
system uh the governor has a seat on
that commission you this you should
design Representatives representatives
to two representatives and the senator
sit on that
commission So speaking of that we're
planning to add a section the house bill
to to repeal or change a whole bunch of
committees and commissions so if you are
a member of any commission that either
number one you don't want to be a member
of right or or you think that the
commission itself doesn't meet that it's
not worth having Etc we would like to
hear about those kind of things right
because we're trying to re in you know
the hundreds of commissions that we have
to appoint people too and many of them
they never meet and then you know things
don't happen so any any suggestions you
can send us to us later but think about
that because I'm sure that you know
you're automatically added to this that
and the other thing right so yeah okay
all right thank you I will do
that okay so then the last one I guess
we going to talk about is uh lchip which
we've already mentioned here and and the
main thing is that the budgeted amount
here is not necessarily equal to the
revenue this is just a big guess right
this this 4.7 million that was spent in
2024 but the income that year was only
about three so um yeses I'm sure that
the folks at elip would be happy to
provide provide more information um
especially on how they've spent down the
fund um over time if you'd like them
too if that's helpful right but the
point is we're budgeting five million
right it's probably it may not be that
it may not end up being that high under
and and as long as we're talking about
lchip there's also in this handout that
you have um the community conservation
endowment you remember the young woman
we had in
here whenever that was last week we were
talking about the
lcip um endowment um and and her work
this is sort of a similar concept here
where the elip board has the when it
says here revenue and funding source
narrative they make sure that whenever
they close a land deal a certain amount
of money goes into an endowment for
stewardship and for oversight of the of
the properties that you know they
help fund or or you know support in some
way so that's what this endowment is all
about and I also explained at the time
that this is what a lot of these land
trusts are doing because they have a big
responsibility when they oversee these
properties so let's ask about that one
so um this is Page 165 Community
conservation Endowment in the in the
dedicated funds hand out so why was
there no Revenue in
2024 that that looks like interest right
so that is a very good question I will
follow up on
it
I sorry I have to believe there was some
right because they closed a whole bunch
of
Grants no but the grant stuff is the
other sources expens expenses yes I'm
not sure what is happen in here ible ask
I'm guessing that the revenue column is
the investment income or interest right
oh I thought it was the endowment that's
the other sources got got yes I will
follow up on this you look I'm not clear
okay so this is the kind of pay yeah on
our other committee we look at this
stuff yeah all the time okay well when
we meet so anyway all right other
questions for the treasurer or should we
let her get back to work I do have one
request if I may um one request that we
we we made to the governor as part of
the governor's budget was to change one
law
to the didn't make it I'm not sure if it
was an oversight I haven't I haven't
received an answer but
um we wanted to change um this statute
that will allow me to appoint more than
two assistant treasurers um right now I
have two assistant treasures and I would
like to be able to reclassify a
classified position to an assistant
treasure position which will be an
unclassified position so by changing the
law and removing the number two will
allow me to reclassify a classified
position to an unclassified position so
essentially um it's not really it
wouldn't have a budgetary impact the
only impact that it what it does right
now is this particular position
uh sometimes uh because it's a is is a
member of management sometimes the
person needs to work more so there's
overtime and limitations as part of the
classified system so um that is a
request I would like to make if if if
you um so this person wouldn't be
appointed by the governor and Council no
it would just be assistant t i i appoint
I appoint assistant Treasurer so it will
be an um an appointee of the treasurer
but you would keep the salary the same
correct it's it's pretty comparable
okay Mr chair go ahead um just so you
don't have to I mean we might have you
back I don't but there's another thing
in hb2 of course we don't have the final
document but there's
another provision in here budget and
Appropriations revolving funds I didn't
know if you wanted to talk about I'm
sorry I didn't get to that that request
relates
to so this is Debt
Service um we were discussing how Debt
Service works and sometimes
um sometimes what we um we typically add
a footnote in the budget for for example
for Debt Service um pay with General
funds but agencies also sometimes have
um again they they we discuss how they
have thatb service and their budgets but
their their budgets um their Debt
Service labs at the end of the fiscal
year uh again with what when we put
together a budget we say in the footnote
that the the funds will lapse at the end
of the bium so sometimes what happens is
if if the estimates of Debt Service are
not good estimates um agencies need to
go before fiscal to request changes in
their line um so what this will do is
essentially it will allow them to now
lapse those funds in the first year of
the of the banum and if they have any um
funds are not spent if they will last at
the end of the vium so this this change
in the law is just adding the
two um
classes there's I guess this existing
law under budge and Appropriations there
are some classes already that don't
lapse in the first year of the banum so
all we're doing is adding debts this The
Debt Service classes
to this group of of of I guess um
budgetary lines that don't lapse until
they lapse until the end of the vum I
guess I should say that uh it's just to
facilitate the payment of Deb service
and uh agencies don't have to go and and
and request funds one of the things that
we don't we don't want to we try not to
ask your permission to pay that service
we have to pay that service um investors
expect us to pay that service so um we
don't want to care investors that we
don't have the funds to pay that service
so this will allow us to just have a
little more flexibility uh it will it
will be part of the law okay sounds
reasonable yes representative thank you
um so when I'm looking at the hb2 you
know the draft we got so it's you've got
in there about um transferring the
Benjamin Thompson fund to UNH and then
you've got what you just discussed about
the debt service and then the third one
is removing two from the assistant
treasurer do you hav't have that statute
I do I have language right here that I
can share with you if they'll probably
keep that will just allow for that the
LBA all right yes so the statue itself
is R say RSA 6 colon 20a and all it will
do right now it says the state treasur
may appoint two assistant treasurers and
the only thing I would like is to remove
the number two okay great that thank you
but I have some that I can share
how about changing two to
three um I don't want to have 20
assistant I I probably don't need 20 but
um you just want one more right um yes I
think right now yes that will that will
that will solve my my concern but like
for example I was looking at the statute
um six stat Secretary of State statutes
they they have a similar language um
than what the treasure statutes show and
they also don't have a number so I was
just narro that you you want to be in
the same category right well when don't
we add a number for them too
so generous with the numbers today yeah
so just but what just so what you're
asking though was unrelated to what you
have had in your presentation you were
asking for authorization for one more
employee to help you track funds and I
just uh I don't even remember that we
talked about that are you struggling to
track all the funds that you
have this was probably the the an ask
and the wrong time of the the the budget
or Rong period but um so we we were
asking for we're we're asking for one
position because um that will be part of
the business office um because what what
what we're going to do is we're going to
um right now we have about 40 trust and
ceral accounts that are maintain and
spreadsheets um that is um that is
something we want to correct and we need
to add all of those funds into the
accounting system
um when that happens obviously the
accounting the accounting will increase
the transactions will increase um so all
we were hoping is that to have an
additional person to help us with that
work um I could completely understand if
that's not possibility this year but we
still um again when we asked um as part
of the agency budget the governor's
budget it it was it was part of it was
included in the in the in in the
governor's
proposal but that's that's the reason we
just it's just additional work that the
business office will have uh again we
will we will man if if that's not
something that can be done this
year
okay is that something a part-time
person or aemp could help with or not
really perhaps I don't believe we have
the ability to have part-time we didn't
budget
oh we didn't budget for a part-time but
but yes I imagine that could be
helpful to quote the chair we can do all
kinds of things
representative cell thank you Mr chair
so if we were to allow a third assistant
uh assistant Treasurer and you appointed
one would they come over as a lateral in
their job grade or would they have to be
promoted into an a higher
grade no the way that salary is
structured that classified position
essentially makes about the same amount
um that an assistant Treasurer makes so
in terms of salary there's really no
change will be a lateral move it's just
it's just a change in the reification
would be a change of title essentially
the duties will be the same it's just
instead of being a classified person
this position will move into to the
unclassified system thank you so they
could work 30 more than 37 and a half
hours a week a little more we tried to
manage that work too without over 10
yeah okay other questions representative
lean
again just for the minutes are you going
to act on this request today or sit on
it for the two additional no we'll we'll
roll them all together okay thank you
sitting sitting anything else no all
right thank you very much thank you very
much hopefully we won't have to see you
again that's
okay
but yeah okay um now for the committee
so this this um spreadsheet I handed
out um this is just you know my own sort
of notes and and um what I put on it
was uh essentially all of
our um all of our agencies as listed in
the index of house bill
one uh the first and last pages those
are the house one
Pages um the fiscal year 19
numbers um those that's adjusted
authorized in fiscal year 19 so one
thing we're using is to compare that
number with the 25 number which is also
an adjusted authorized number where is
the fiscal year
um the the fiscal year 24 number is an
actual right so you you understand the
difference um and then the the next two
numbers are the governor's budget
numbers so just as a now all of these
are General funds with the exception of
two lines so for
doit and for
oplc I put in their total I'm sorry and
liquor for three of these so for doit
for oplc and for liquor I put in the
total funds number not the general funds
number because they don't have they have
essentially no General funds or very
little but but for
doit a significant part of that is
General funds right but they' all flow
via some other agency at least half
right at Le yeah maybe probably about
half I guess be my guess but you know
they got Highway funds they got federal
funds and all this sort of stuff and
then for uh oplc it's all total
funds um and
um just but just by way of
comparison
um you know the money they spend comes
out of everybody's professional licenses
right so uh and they they that's a hard
one to compare because we've changed
over the years we've significantly
changed which kinds of professions they
handle right so so it's hard to compare
you know apples and apples from year to
year and then uh liquor while everything
they spend is is liquor funds
but uh whatever they don't spend becomes
General funds right so so it's very
important not to spend in order to you
know yeah so so we can think of this as
all General funds if you want to um
perhaps so anyways that's that's the
um uh that's the story on this stuff
okay um and then all the notes are just
you know my own little um thoughts but
you know obviously um none of those
things are official or whatever you know
yes go ahead um aside from the Liquor
Commission are there any other
departments where that their unspent
revenue goes to the general fund but
their expenses don't
well no I mean Dees
doesn't lapse to the general fund or
something right I mean it's D collects a
lot of
fees sure they spend them and what they
have in excess would go to the general
fund but we don't know what that figure
is okay yeah I guess that makes
sense um Mr chair yes go ahead to I I
realize we don't have hb2 here and we're
waiting for it like oh oh wait do you
have an announcement breaking news yes
breaking news hb1 hb2 and hb25 are
public and posted on the
website Jack and I will get you copies
25 is the capital bu thank you yeah Jack
and I will you copy of those go home and
read them tonight so so for for me to
understand better what the situation is
for our division it would be really
helpful to know what of HB b
2 is in
hb1 so like the group two retirement I
I'm not maybe you guys you probably know
the answer I I know that the municipal
Revenue sharing is
in
hb1 right so I think it would be just
better to understand I can ask my
opinion tomorrow when I see him does he
have a surplus statement that includes
all of hb2 in it right which he may or
may not have yet so so at some point not
not too long we'll have a surplus
statement Surplus statement is what
changes hb1 via hb2 and other bills to
get to the actual bottom line right so
so that's what we that's what you're
asking for basically basically yes well
because I just think we'd have a better
idea of what our what we're working with
absolutely
if we knew that because those are both
Big Ticket items right and the well and
the original Surplus statement from the
governor really had nothing on it right
there were no so so like for example the
group two
stuff is in here right the the something
it I mean the 5 million the first year
and the 28 million the second year it is
it is we're not sure that that's what is
reflected in
H2 well this is nodding at me go ahead
so yes it is in both places um I believe
the governor was supposed to request it
to be taken out of hb2 because it was an
hb1 and I don't think that happened so
it'll probably need to be an amendment
that we do we being division one does to
hb2 what we don't know what the question
is what the actual cost of the group to
calculation is because as we heard from
New Hampshire retirement system that
figure did not come from them so what is
in hb1 is an estimate from the
governor's office but we need to verify
that what the actual expense of this
Bill yes the the retirement system does
not like working on something that's not
an official draft right so now that we
have hb2 we can give them those pages
and then they can come up ask their
actuaries and give us whatever the real
numbers so those two numbers are just
guesses and that would repace educ
okay yeah um You probably saw breaking
news too they add to Melissa that Ways
and Means came out with their numbers
today yeah but I think I already had
those right so did they
change Mela did they change there's $256
million shortfall for
26 the same yeah for 25 youan 26
compared to 25
26 yeah yeah okay okay in any case yes I
think those are all the numbers that we
had um so um what I didn't hand out yet
but we've talked about is
um aside from
YDC the size that we're going to try to
cut in this division is something like
65 million a year in order to get from
the governor's Revenue estimates to the
house Ways and Means Revenue estimates
okay so that's kind of that's my the
ballpark of what I I understand what's
the figure about 65 million per year 66
million something like that
um from the governor's budget the
difference between the governor's budget
and what house ways mean says we have
for
Revenue okay um
now there's all kinds of ways to do
stuff um and some of it is you know
laying off people and and some of it
is um reducing grants and and other sort
of outside spending and some of it
is
um not giving back to towns as much as
uh as we would have otherwise
um but you know the the all the uses of
money uh some of it is Raising fees and
fines and and that kind of stuff right
and back of the budget stuff yeah back
of the budget cuts you know well when we
make a cut we can make it specifically
to an accounting unit right um and
there's also General sorts of things so
for example one of the things I'm
looking at is
um how many employees so Statewide
there's there's uh I now have a
spreadsheet with something like 20,000
state employees on it okay um positions
not people you know I don't know names
but position and um and so I I know
who's who supervises who okay and so it
turns out there's a significant number
of people on that list that super
supervis one person okay and there's a
large number that supervis two people
and there's a large number that supervis
three people and the number of people
who
supervise like five or more is
small so you know the the general
structure management structure of state
government is
is you know fairly um fairly steep I
guess if you want to think of it that
way as opposed to what a standard
organization might have of you know if
you're a manager you manage 10 people or
something like that
now anyways so that's something we can
think about as kind of a general thing
is do we want to get you know fewer
supervisors and make them more workers
and less supervisors because it's to
some extent it's a little bit of a trick
to get somebody paid more is to change
their title from your whatever to your
whatever supervisor right that gets you
into a higher pay grade so you know
that's more of a general kind of thing
we can do to save money um yes go ahead
actually delay delayering an
organization as what you suggested is
actually a very good management practice
not just Financial because it drives
decision making to a lower level where
those people are probably more able to
come to a solution I mean if if a
machine is broken the person that
operates the machine is probably going
to know what needs to be done to fix it
than somebody to grade levels above them
so I I think it's it would be a good
exercise yeah but it's but it's hard to
do those would end up being sort of back
of the budget type things right that
says reduce your number of Supervisors
by you know X right you know this kind
of thing so um but anyways so there's
there's all kinds of ways to save money
um and we will be looking at them all so
you said 65 million per year so 130 for
the bayum something like that
yeah from division one and we are like
19% of of the general funds total okay
now um the biggest number we have I
think um besides Corrections so so and
some of these are going to be very hard
to cut right because like Corrections
for
example um they seem to come in with a
very type budget right I mean they're
it's flat from what they're actually
spent last year and um I'm concerned
that it's as I told them that it's
unrealistic because because they
essentially took away all the all the um
um overtime that they were actually
using right they have like 40% of their
budget is overtime or something like
that and so yeah but she was going to
offset that with the UN un the vacant
positions right and that that's a good
strategy yeah it's reasonable right and
and we've been talking about for
example getting rid of uh liquor
enforcement right so there's there's
group
two uh employees there that could become
corrections employees right and so you
know that's another thing is I I think
we should take a hard look at group two
employees who are scattered around right
and and do they really need to be um you
know does every little Department well I
don't know how many do but what
departments need a police force and what
don't right so I think uh maybe there's
some in agriculture for example right
that don't have to be there so send them
all to Corrections
Corrections is hiring they have openings
they have openings yeah yeah there's no
question about it so I mean there's
those are all kinds of things we have to
think about um all these new initiatives
uh things we get in
bills um those are going to be hard to
fund you know I
mean for every one of those things you
fund you have to cut yet more right in
another place yes represent
they so on the bail reform I remember
remember in the judicial branch I think
it was 1.8 million yes per
year is somebody
calculating the difference in that cost
based if the provision that they are
voting out of committee passes do you
know what I'm trying to I really haven't
looked at that bill so I don't know yeah
but that might but yeah assum assum we
get that bill it'll have a fiscal note
and then we'll talk about it
I'm it it appears to me from what you
know the Judiciary was saying was that
what we did last time didn't work very
well specific well MoneyWise the the
money paid to the uh bail Commissioners
right remember they used to go and
collect them from from the accused
directly right or or via their judge
right but now the uh Judiciary is paying
the bail Commissioners and then the
judici is is running after the um uh
defendants to grab the money right and
they're not doing a great job of it
right so they were saying they're
getting you know they're they're getting
a sixth or something of what they're of
what they're being paid you know so so
that whole thing doesn't seem to be
working very well now maybe because it's
new I don't know but but you know that
would be a significant chunk of this 1.8
million that we might want to think
about 3.6 over the exactly because it's
3.6 over the by any so you know um and I
don't think that's all bail commissioner
I mean some of that is the magistrate
salary that was the other thing I was
curious about because I didn't I don't
know if Melissa or Jack knew how that
broke down those numbers between the
cost of the magistrates versus the bail
[Music]
Commissioners it's just like I don't
know the top of my head
but I'd be curious to know I mean the
whole concept there was that we weren't
getting as many bail Commissioners as we
wanted right so therefore we hire a
magistrate so I don't
know it wasn't well wasn't well received
by the
existing B
commission yes and and uh turn on your
microphone and we had a case recently
where I believe it was one of the new
magistrates
uh there was some controversies about
his
performance yeah I I'd be right there
there was some you know big incident but
but I as I understand it later the judge
backed up that Magistrate's decision yes
right so therefore you know you can't
you can't just run around making law
based on one specific incident right you
know so and and I thought the judicial
branch actually liked the Magistrate
because it relieved the burden on a lot
of the Judes yes and they much less
expensive than judges that's right so so
the key is how much staff do they have
and do they have to have quite so much
right so that's what I've been talking
to people about because and and you
remember you asked was it you that asked
the question of the governor yes and she
said they've got two parallel
scheduling sets of Staff right that that
could be could be merged and they could
could find some uh savings so you know
there's there's that question as well
well and so the the other thing though
is as we're looking at all these
individual boards that provide
alternatives to going to
court that if you didn't have those
opportunities there would be quite an
additional burden on the court
so the whole uh my whole sweater analogy
when you start I'm not arguing one way
or the other I'm just saying we've got
to look at the whole box wax sure and I
also Mr chair I also think that when we
look at the investment in diversion
programs that that's a wise decision
because there is a great expense when
someone's incarcerated so when we do
have opportunities for pro to fund
programs that will lessen the amount
people that need bail or people that
need to be incarcerated I think that's
that's spending that's smart right and I
would certainly consider a high
representative Smith do you come to
berate me
or
no okay um because I I think I did
something you may not have liked today
but anyway um already confessing yeah
well I knew it at the time but anyways
um but I might be
willing we we talked about for example
the the Thousand that separates a
misdemeanor from a felony right and
that's probably been there for who knows
how many years but I that's not
something I feel comfortable changing in
the budget right you know it could save
us money right but but um that's a big
deal I think right so that you know
maybe representative eel and I could
sponsor a bill next year or something
like that we could look at it I mean
I'll send you the article he made a it
was the head of the office of the public
defender and it just shows you again
using the sweater theory if you change a
little something here it can Ripple all
through the system because you didn't
need as many Defenders you you know less
burden on the judicial branch maybe less
people
incarcerated it was I don't know it just
really struck me but it wouldn't be I
mean we do have President especially in
the last couple terms of putting in
those kind of policy things in the
budget so it it it's something I don't
think we should discount if we know that
it's going to have savings um but um
there you know another thing that came
up I think in the judicial branch it
came up when we were discussing um
representative walner bill regarding
Waypoint is um maybe running a pilot
excuse me or investing in a pilot for
the young adult court because that's
been shown to be a good
diversion um you know and I I think it
it might might be you know it it may
cost a probationary officer but other
than that I think that's something we
should look at even though it's an add
to the budget it would actually
decrease um the number of people who
would be
incarcerated and not just on the short
term but the long term too so just
things like that
okay be an adjunct of the Judiciary
Committee um could I just suggest Mr
chair for hb2 on Friday it would I don't
I don't well also it will be Wednesday
morning right we're doing hp2 well I was
thinking so we should have them I I was
thinking about the dees part on the SEC
the site evaluation committee and and
the permitting it would be good to hear
from them some sort of concept of the
related costs because that's not really
I mean I saw fee
increases right and then we saw I think
the governor added 275
,000 for the permitting I think that was
it so I think I don't know I'm just
trying to get a better understanding
yeah and then on that permitting thing
as I mentioned to you it does involve
dncr and fishing game so somebody from
those agencies I think should be here
for the discussion yeah because it it's
their employees that are getting pulled
so Melissa are you when yours when we
should we try to kind of group group
things in in in the house build 2 and
get appropriate agency here when it's a
significant item I mean there some of
these things are little tiny things like
like the treasurer mentioned right we
don't really need anybody back but other
things are pages and Pages worth PES and
Pages yeah so we've tried to Jack and I
have tried to coordinate that um for
instance on Friday we have Dees coming
in we do know division 2 will talk with
fishing game on their portion of it um
if you want to invite them in I would
just say the chair probably should
correspond with representative F yeah
I'll do that to discuss that see them
tomorrow um Wednesday you talked about
retirement talking about retirement so
we're inviting retirement in because
it's important for them to discuss that
piece even though they won't have a cost
yet they will be able to talk about some
of the comparisons and differences so
typically if we think we're going to
tackle a subject and it's outside the
expertise that Jack and I can provide
then we would invite an agency in if
it's something that we can get the
information or we know what it does then
we don't invite the agency in and we
just vote on it as is sure so do you
think we have the capacity as far as the
permitting issues to think about dncr
without dncr a staff person being here I
mean because it's their employees that
are getting all I was thinking is if we
do hb2 with Dees on Friday afternoon if
we start with the permitting thing maybe
somebody we could ask them if they want
to be here maybe some somebody from dncr
and fishing game would just like to be
here for the discussion I I'm really
struggling to understand how we Gap
understand the whole picture here if we
don't have the input of the other
agencies I mean we always can invite
anybody in that you guys feel is
necessary to come in how we even I mean
DS is the recipient of all these things
I don't know how the others feel about
it yeah so we can invite dncr and like I
said fishing game I would probably just
request the chair to speak to
representative Earth to make sure we're
sort of not sipping on anybody's toes or
any division's toes if they we want to
invite their agencies in to speak with
us and we also don't we do not have to
complete it all on Friday so if we have
Dees in and then we need another day we
always can schedule another day or
another time slot for additional
questions I I don't know how much there
I mean I know fishing game is over there
today so I don't know how much they
would have talked about this but they're
not digging into hb2 yet they're doing
budget work right now
okay I don't want to make a big de it's
just it's a multiple pages of this
document y represent thank you Mr chair
do we know what the schedule's going to
be like next week just plan on
essentially Monday Wednesday Friday from
for every day for the March in March
okay um and they probably will be the
when we get to the end and have to vote
in the main committee that could easily
be Tuesday to yeah and do we know
anything about the public hearing for
hb1 and two what the so I think we made
the assumption that it may be on the
12th um we don't have full confirmation
of that Janet just got notification of
the hb2 so she works on scheduling that
with representative wer yeah I haven't
heard so will you be making I'm sure
we'll talk about it so I I have a
regular meeting with the other chairs
and my K on Tuesday Mornings so um I'm
sure that'll be tomorrow morning
tomorrow morning exactly so so should we
request hb2 copies or you guys going to
have them made we will get copies for
you and as well um for those you have
been on the committee in the past Jack
and I will go through and index it for
division one items only so we don't
cover other divisions but we do make an
index of the sections we need to cover
because we need to make sure we vote on
those in the end of what we're doing
with them and we'll keep track of
that so we'll look online tonight and
then we'll have one in the morning
if it's available I think
that's sometime tomorrow sometime okay
sometime tomorrow the issue I was I'll
just mention with with representative
Smith um there's a bill in um Judiciary
to get rid of the office of Cost
Containment so this is related to the
judicial Council because when people get
a um when they're Indigent and they get
an attorney
the
money they actually are sort of
borrowing the money they're not
necessarily given it and and so there's
a there's an office called the office of
Cost Containment which tries to recover
the some of these costs and what
happened was over the years and and they
used to be profitable in the sense that
that the cost of the agency was much
less than the amount they were bringing
in you know they were bringing in a
couple million dollar a year or
something and but a few years a like
2020 we changed the law such that people
who were
innocent uh didn't have to pay back okay
and um so the whole thing not that that
many people are found innocent right
very few are but but what the the result
was that um and they don't check very
much exactly how Indigent people are
right and so um and so the result was
that their revenue dropped off
considerably based on that change to the
law and um so it it it has dropped to
the point where the cost of the office
is slightly greater than the cost what
they're bringing in so representative
Smith and others put in a bill why don't
we just get rid of this office and in
fact the governor did in the budget if
you look at the budget but
representative Lynn complained to me
that that um he doesn't think it's right
for people who
are
um people do owe this the the cost of
their attorneys right I mean if if if an
if a well-to-do person is accused of
something goes to court you know hires
an attorney goes to court is found
innocent and so on they still owe their
attorney I mean it's just that's one of
the costs of life and so uh he thinks
that's one of the costs of life you know
and so
we this bill that representative Smith
had I just all Yes um so representative
Lyn and myself made an amendment to
Simply undo the thing that was done in
2020 so that this office of Cost
Containment could now be profitable back
again right could be
put well it was at some
point it won't be now people can't pay
they can't pay so they don't pay I don't
care how much you harass them they can't
collect the money well somehow they used
to pay well they used to but it hasn't
for years and we're spending a lot of
money trying to get money that and
Charlie Arling house is completely in
favor of getting rid of this Cost
Containment and it's going to cost us
money Dan it it has
and uh it's something I think we can do
without because if somebody doesn't have
the money they don't have the money is
you can keep chasing them and spend a
ton of money on lawyers for the state
yeah well eventually they turn all I
have on my side is history I mean old
history what do they do after a year not
that old do they turn it over to a
collections agency you know what do they
do yeah well they are the collection
agents that's what but they're Lo
they've been losing money for over a can
they put the person in jail for not
paying right they won't but the point is
if you read the fiscal note on this bill
it says due to previous legislative
changes the amount collected by this dat
has declined over the years well so this
bill can undo those previous legislative
changes anyway so that's what this whole
thing was that's why you got the look Mr
that's why I got the
look it sounds like a part-time job that
could be done by an existing employee in
the Justice Department not a number of
lawyers which are on the payroll now
there's there's I think three or four
people and uh but you know they used to
collect couple million dollars
so
anyway that's that's the the whole
question so that bill if it passes will
come to us I guess we will see but I
think if nothing is done right if the
bill
fails
then then it's out of the budget it's
it's not in the budget right now right
so no but if you look at 26 27 all is
zeros so the governor took it out so it
must be in house Bill too this bill the
the fact of this bill must be in the
house bill
to yeah I just know it's
notes oh it's not so the budget just
assumed that this bill was going to pass
I mean that's kind of weird I think when
commissioner Arling house uh came in
that is what he said that they
assumed and if something different were
to come of it then we'd need to add
money back in
it's but I'm going to assume Revenue
then I appreciate your
optimism you can't get blood out of a
stone more
turn all right we'll give you we'll give
Melissa a project of what what was the
revenue that the office of Cost
Containment made in 2019 or prior to
when whenever this was done
so we have a slug of bills on Wednesday
so we'll see yeah I mean if if a if a um
sponsor comes in here and even though
we're here there's it's coming here you
know some of these bills come and
there's no fiscal effect at all if we
like them can we just send them their on
their merry way without retraining
them yeah so the whole strategy with
bills is a question right so um we'll
have to see what they are we'll have to
see what they are yeah we have to read
them before we vote
on there was quite a there's quite a few
of them yes these all bills that pass
the house yes we're going to get more
and we're going to get lots more yeah
it's just I was just thinking I think
we're up to about nine or 10
yeah I like some of your suggestions on
here but which leads me to a question Mr
chair now what we retained what four or
five bills some of them have significant
ask and are you going to assume that
we're just going to dispense with those
since we already know we're $65 million
shy is that your plan or yes I mean you
know there's the $100,000 for the
agriculture thing I mean I don't know
we're going to do that 50,000 50,000 I
we can offset it we can do it let's work
on getting the 65 down first
yeah see where we're at but I don't
think we can afford any of retirement
bills that we retained
or but but what I'm concerned about
there
is what we did two years ago kind of
assumed we would be keep paying for 10
years are we all of a sudden going to
say let's just put it on the towns you
know youum whatever you want each each
legislature has to vote on everything
separately you can't vote for future
legisl that's right yeah repr brellas is
absolutely correct you can't and then
there's the YDC thing right I mean well
we know that's going to be a $75 million
hit no matter what but it's but it's not
here I know it's not
there they're going to have to stretch
what they got for this
year we
H oh yeah we we You' you you have a a
draft Yeah so what is the what's What's
the total money oh MoneyWise no we don't
think that there's much there at all
right they're going to figure it out
they they'll figure it out and I may get
the number tomorrow morning but but
um we don't think there's much number
there's much of a number there um now
one big thing in hb2 is the video
Lottery
terminals right and so
um that's a big question mark cuz cuz we
haven't heard from way Ways and Means
about that Revenue right they they
included didn't they in their they have
their own bill they haven't yet exected
as far as I
know um and from their point of view
it's not an early bill so oh come on
guys it has
to yeah so I've asked them to treat it
like an early bill but we'll see
so huh
that would go to lottery so that would
be division too oh than God at this
point it's a self-fulfilling prophecy
because they the governor's already said
not that they're going to get the money
I don't think I see any way they're
going to get 100 they're not going to
get 127 million the first year there's
no way not with everybody going Foxwoods
and moan son but that's not what the
budget says the budget says 10 million
the first year
117 the second year yeah but I still
don't think going to get 117 second year
but at this point they've almost they've
committed to it so the bill is going to
get passed by the house and the Senate
and the governor is going to sign
it no they may not have my vote but
they're going to pass it I know that you
think so yeah I think so they have to
it's like at this point he's committed
it's like there 117 million on the
second year that but they have to have
there's an awful lot of details there
that
different members of the House are
concerned about and like I'm concerned
about it I wouldn't I might not vote for
it necessarily but a lot of the pressure
is going to be we need this Revenue the
pressure is going to be there so right
but some people think that the revenue
she put in is unrealistic in particular
the split between the operator and the
um and the state and the Charities is
all quite different than than current
practice the mafia usually wants a
bigger cut yeah so I don't think we're
GNA get 45% or what yeah yeah well who's
the mafia in this situation right
somebody is it the state
somebody
I and there's and there's likely to be a
floor Amendment or two making it a
dedicated fund for some special purpose
well yeah I mean I personally think it
should simply go to the education trust
fund
consider it like all gambling right and
then and then we adjust we can adjust
the the other splits that go to the
education trust fund don't you mean
general fund you should go to general
fund and then we can no I think if you
want to be clean with the Constitution
just put all gambling money in the
education trust fund and be done with it
but there's all kinds of other money
that goes the education trust and
doesn't have to right so does the
Constitution say all again money must no
it says it says lottery I believe right
and
so you know so yeah but just to make it
clean you know what I mean I would
you you know I mean it's a New Concept I
mean it's quite you know this stuff is
silly um I mean this part of the
Constitution is a little bit silly right
because because a dollar here
you know every dollar is the same as
another dollar right and so the fact
that this dollar went for that purpose
you know well what about that
dollar can go to this purpose you know
what I mean a TR it's not a trust fund
it's it's a it sounds it sounds good but
you know in reality it's that's why we
always talk about General and education
funds in one phrase right because they
really are the same okay all right
but but they're non-aps so um that's
another another thing okay any other
things we want to talk about in general
before we go caucus I mean I just think
we're going to be watching bills to see
what effect they may make changes that
might pass through the the um budget
right so there was remember when we were
talking about the new the Paid Family
Leave they were talking about a bill
that was going to remove the marketing
from their responsibilities which was
about
$500,000 so we'll see if that comes
through Commerce do you remember that
say that again so on the New Hampshire
Paid Family Leave we were when we were
talking about the New Hampshire Paid
Family Leave With Das we were looking at
their budget and part of their
responsibility is marketing the program
remember and there was I thought there
was something like
$500,000 in there for marketing yes we
were asking about that but then she said
there was a bill in Commerce that she I
don't that they may um remove the
promotion
responsibilities of Das for
that as part of a bill and then we may
get that yes and that would be quite a
bit of money right there yeah so there
may be other bills like that we'll see
sure yeah there may be some bills well
for example there's a bill to get rid of
the U consumer Advocate right right so
if that bill passes all federal funds um
no it's other funds that go to rate
payers the rate payers would benefit the
rate payers would benefit yeah well well
the rid payers benefit by his um
advocating on their behalf as
well yeah so the you know that's the
theory
anyway yeah um okay other any other
issues anybody wants to bring up all
right we'll see you uh Wednesday morning
at 10: if not sooner people make a
little
money you all stand when you get
up not yet
what for